[Musique]
et va Sadoun bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
retrouvons
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succincts
dans l'aspect révolution de la finance
c'est-à-dire que notre objectif c'est de
complètement transformer en profondeur
le secteur financier bon on le fait
modestement aujourd'hui mais on essaie
d'apporter notre pierre à l'édifice avec
des solutions d'investissement
participatif accessibles grand public
pour les particuliers pour leur
permettre d'investir dans une économie
réelle du terrain durable solidaire qui
propose une vraie alternative au modèle
économique actuel et de l'autre côté à
travers des outils data de
transparisation des produits d'épargne
donc on a beaucoup travaillé pendant
plus de 3 ans à essayer de recomposer
les produits d'épargne et comprendre en
fait concrètement derrière une assurance
vie un livret un compte courant
qu'est-ce qui se cache quelles
entreprises se cachent quel projet sont
réellement financés donc ça c'est la
partie entrepreneur et je milite
également beaucoup je fais pas mal de
lobbying à travers un syndicat un
nouveau syndicat une sorte alternative
écologique et social au Medef qui
s'appelle le mouvement impact France
sont représentent plus de 15000
dirigeants qui veulent proposer des
politiques économiques alignées avec des
enjeux transition écologiques et
sociales puis j'ai sorti un petit
bouquin récemment qui s'appelle une
économie à nous j'essaye aussi de de
d'apporter quelque chose ma pierre à
l'édifice à la pensée économique pour
qu'elle soit plus écologique sociale et
puis féministe
alors avant d'aborder votre background
parce qu'il y a avant tout ça
vous mettez des informations sur la
table donc je vous pose tout de suite
les informations ça pèse combien ça
représente combien de personnes c'est
réglementé comment aujourd'hui cette
interview n'a pas de but à vous faire
investir et n'a aucun but de conseil en
investissement
vos boîtes s'apaisent combien combien
vous gagnez combien vous sortez combien
ça fait
modeste pour l'instant donc c'est plus
de 130 millions d'euros qui ont été
levés auprès de particulier de 25000
donc sur la plateforme il y a plus de
35000 particuliers donc des individus
vraiment avec des patrimoines très
différenciés quoi c'est hyper hétérogène
qui ont investi 120 millions 130
millions d'euros à peu près depuis 5-6
ans dans des projets très variés comme
je vous disais avec une un tropisme
quand même pour tout ce qui est
agroécologie énergie renouvelables etc
en termes de de revenus pour nous c'est
à peu près 4 millions de suffit
d'affaires l'année dernière donc c'est
c'est assez faible c'est 60 personnes
c'est une PME qui est présente en France
Belgique-Italie et qui est en cours
d'europhanisation et on va se lancer
bientôt aussi dans certains pays
africains et côté rift c'est une petite
boîte c'est une boîte de Data et donc on
est beaucoup moins on est trois quatre
alors avant rift ce qu'on va en parler
drift
vous prenez un pourcentage sur les
investissements qui passent chez vous il
comme comment ça se passe absolument
c'est pas transparent en gros nous le
but c'est désintermédié donc de faire
face à l'opacité au manque de
transparence à la surintermédiation du
secteur financier pour permettre aux
particuliers réellement d'investir en
direct d'acheter des actions des
obligations de ces boîtes écologiques
sociales et sur les flux absolument tout
ce qui est investi il y a une com de 5%
côté entreprise et autour de 2% côté
investisseurs et après il y a plus de
fracassés quoi et après les
investisseurs payent plus rien ça dépend
vraiment de la typologie d'entreprise
dans lequel ils ont investi et les
retours sont assez différents parce
qu'en fait on peut proposer des boîtes
en mode limite
limite c'est du c'est limite de la
philanthropie sur des activités
ultra-sociales et des boîtes ou
effectivement il y a un rendement plus
intéressant quand c'est pas de
l'éco-construction ou la production
d'énergie ou là c'est des entreprises
qui ont des modèles économiques qui sont
un peu plus favorables quoi qu'est-ce
que vous entendez par rendement donc
quand on investit donc c'est à travers
deux types de produits donc nous on fait
de l'investissement c'est pas du prêt
c'est pas garanti c'est hyper liquide
faut le ça il faut le savoir c'est le
nom l'investissement non coté ça a
énormément de vertus l'investissement de
nos côtés c'est tout ce qui est pas côté
en bourse c'est énormément de vertus
parce que c'est directement investi dans
l'économie réelle dans des PME que vous
pouvez côtoyer et soutenir chaque jour
mais le versant de ça c'est que c'est
e-liquide c'est à dire vous pouvez pas
revendre vos actions au revendre vos
obligations comme ça sur un marché donc
il faut rester il faut être on est lié à
l'aventure d'une entreprise donc que
vous soyez en obligation c'est à dire
que vous avez des intérêts annuels ou en
action donc vous avez un titre de
capital vous pouvez avoir des droits de
vote etc dans une boîte pas de dividende
vraiment versé faut être tout à fait
du tout c'est à dire qu'en fait la
manière dont ça se passe vu qu'on
investit dans des entreprises qui sont
assez jeunes c'est à dire elles ont
moins de 20 ans ces boîtes là elles
permettent elles font pas réellement de
dividendes elles partagent pas elles
n'ont pas de bénéfices à proprement
parler elle peut elles vont partager la
valeur essentiellement en interne dans
elles vont réinvestir dans l'entreprise
par contre la plus-value donc ce que les
personnes pour obtenir c'est dans le cas
où l'entreprise va vendre les parts des
individus à un autre fond
d'investissement ou un ou fusionner avec
un concurrent le scénario possible non
allez-y un commentaire de la communauté
qui dit elle parle trop vite on n'arrive
pas à enregistrer et ben il y a une
fonction sur Youtube après ce sera
ralentir ralentir ok je vais essayer de
parler quand même plus lentement restez
comme vous êtes restez comme vous êtes
c'est très important
revenons au départ
si j'ai encore une question en termes de
réglementation de régulation qu'est-ce
qui vous surveille c'est la MF c'est
quoi donc c'est l'Autorité des marchés
financiers qui est en charge de réguler
l'ensemble des marchés donc autant les
gros émetteurs type des grosses boîtes
du CAC 40 qui mettent leurs actions sur
les marchés que les sociétés de gestion
c'est à dire les fonds d'investissement
qui vont proposer des placements et qui
vont investir que les acteurs comme nous
qui proposons de la l'investissement de
côté donc nous on est aujourd'hui
conseiller en investissements
participatif au titre de l'AMF et on va
bientôt avoir un passeport européen
voilà pendant l'exercice notre activité
je réponds à Elijah Elijah c'est un pavé
que tu m'as mis mais je vais essayer de
le lire pendant l'interview ok tu peux
vaquer tes occupations
revenons à nos moutons avant tout ça
quel a été votre parcours scolaire votre
perception du parcours scolaire quel a
été le déclic et qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à sortir du bois au milieu de ce
biotope financier archaïque machiste et
j'en passais des meilleurs voir une
petite jeunette débarquée comme ça ils
ont dû vous regarder de haut
reste à ta place sois gentil t'y connais
rien non c'est ça
j'aimerais vous dire que le contraire
mais c'était pas le cas donc
effectivement moi j'ai à l'origine
plutôt eu une vocation d'investissement
politique c'est à dire que mon objectif
était de transformer vraiment la manière
dont le système fonctionnel et ce que
j'avais pas réalisé avant la crise de
2008 c'est à quel point en fait le
système était essentiellement la colonne
vertébrale de l'économie qui était le
système financier c'est vraiment le
déclic que j'ai eu en 2008 et à cette
époque là j'étais un peu perdue entre
des engagements politiques des
absolument moi c'est très important
d'entendre en fait vos émotions autour
du déclic qu'est-ce que comment ça a été
vécu comment ça a été ressenti quel a
été le mode opératoire pour verbaliser
et mettre en oeuvre ce déclic
je suis désolé non mais on va y venir on
va y venir parce qu'en fait ça fait
partie de c'est à dire qu'il y a jamais
un des clics uniques c'est à dire 2008
c'était quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a
choqué on en parlait autant qu'un a dans
ta théorie donc une révolution politique
ou sociale et en même temps on se
rendait on comprenait rien en fait très
honnêtement à 18 ans déjà je ne
comprenais rien la plupart des gens n'y
comprenait pas grand chose et derrière
c'était même utilisé dans les dans les
mouvements politiques comme ou
l'étendard d'un mouvement ProFinance où
les standard d'un mouvement
anti-finances et finalement je me suis
dit si j'ai envie de comprendre comment
le système fonctionne il faut que
j'aille expérimenter surtout qu'en plus
j'étais plutôt une batteuse voilà donc
c'était plus simple pour moi d'avoir des
ce système j'ai toujours aimé déchiffrer
les choses et surtout essayer de rentrer
dans des univers qui m'était fermés et
là clairement le système financier il y
avait peu de portes ouvertes donc j'ai
bossé j'ai fait des matchs j'ai fait de
la finance de marché j'ai fait une avis
de danse d'entreprise j'ai intégré une
grande école etc le mien
un peu par inadvertance en fait je
voulais plutôt travailler dans les
études économiques et financières et
intégrer Normal Sup et j'ai raté mon
oral de normal donc j'ai intégré cette
école avec un peu de suspicion parce que
pour moi l'univers des écoles de
commerce des grandes écoles c'est tout
le système appliqué donc on peut pas
réinventer le système dans le lieu dans
lequel c'est juste le système s'exerce
n'est même pas pensé et en fait je pense
d'une fabrique de clown
c'est l'idée que j'avais en tout cas en
avance de ce milieu là
et en même temps j'ai jamais été
quelqu'un aussi qui portait trop de
jugement sur les autres pour être tout à
fait honnête donc en fait j'avais pas je
méprisais pas les gens de ces grandes
écoles et j'étais sûr pouvoir en tout
cas il apprend quelque chose parce que
on peut réinventer un système sans
vraiment confronter réellement et c'est
ce que j'ai eu envie de faire c'est pour
ça que j'ai fait cette école c'est pour
ça que j'ai appris la finance la finance
de marché c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé
de bosser dans des banques dans une
banque j'ai essayé aussi de réinventer
la finance et d'apprendre la
microfinance en Inde etc et surtout
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé plutôt de
partir sur l'entrepreneuriat plutôt que
d'intégrer un milieu financier
traditionnel dans lequel on pouvait pas
réinventer et il y avait un précepteur
de qui m'a beaucoup inspiré qui
s'appelle Mohamed Younous qui est
l'inventeur du micro crédit je pense
qu'ici vous êtes assez aguerri sur les
sujets financiers dont beaucoup de vais
connaître Mohamed youz qui est
d'ailleurs le prix Nobel de la paix
c'est assez drôle
savoir que c'est pour moi plutôt un prix
Nobel d'économie en soi donc c'est la
paix absolument mais ce serait
intéressant aussi de voir ces
innovations sociales écologique dans le
milieu économique comme quelque chose de
sérieux vous voyez en fait le fait qu'il
ait été pas mis dans la sur la scène des
prix Nobels d'économie ça dit quelque
chose et toujours été je trouve quelque
chose de problématique et ça l'est
encore aujourd'hui c'est à dire que le
milieu progressiste et vu un peu comme
quelque chose d'alternative de
philosophique de sociologie alors que on
essaie de réinventer quand même le
système c'est très sérieux ce qu'on fait
et ce qui dit Mohamed Younous c'est que
la bonne manière
de décortiquer de transformer un système
c'est d'arriver avec son innocence et
c'est vraiment ça qui s'est passé entre
moi et la finance c'est à dire que je
suis arrivé dans un système dans lequel
je connaissais peu de choses j'ai bossé
dessus d'un point de vue académique mais
j'ai entrepris directement j'ai pas
voulu faire 10 ans de banque 10 ans de
société de gestion j'ai voulu
entreprendre directement pour essayer de
de transformer système et d'y apporter
quelque chose de nonopaque de
transparent et de durable surtout
alors c'est apporter son innocence
je vais faire la voie du diable motorisé
c'est un peu votre marque de fabrique
pour transformer un système il faut
comprendre un moindre de ces rouages
de l'Intérieur faire un cheval de Troie
c'est-à-dire une fois que vous l'avez
compris entièrement vous pouvez cibler
là où vous pouvez le faire chuter ou
vous pouvez cibler comment l'améliorer
on est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
est-ce qu'on perd pas un peu son
innocence au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années quand on se rend compte quand
on se rend compte de la réalité des
rouages qui peuvent être un peu graisse
un peu lourd un peu dogmatique on peut
idéologique et est-ce que la le système
financier mondial qui pèse je sais plus
quoi 30 000 milliards de dollars par an
il faut que je suis désolé on a une
plateforme de fact checking appuie sur
le bouton
Patrick Artus si vous voulez vérifier
merci
je me suis trompé que de quoi un zéro
une décimal c'est ça
on s'en remet jamais
des marchés financiers de cet argent
est-ce que quand on arrive avec son
innocence
ça a bienveillance est-ce que ça
ressemble pas un petit peu à une mouche
qui qui vient s'éclater sur une sur un
pare-brise de camion qui roule à 90 sur
l'autoroute on joue pas avec les mêmes
armes c'est à dire que c'est certain que
je joue pas avec les armes de du nombre
de milliards gérés
je joue pas avec les armes de la
puissance ni du réseau ni mais je joue
avec des armes actuelles qui sont des
armes encore plus fortes qui sont des
armes culturelles et c'est une vraie
pâte à culturelle qu'on mène en montrant
déjà que un système financier différent
non opaque est possible en montrant que
c'est possible de rentrer transparent un
produit c'est qu'il y ait une décision
politique et une décision de du secteur
économique de ne pas rendre ce secteur
transparent et en montrant finalement
que tout le monde peut le comprendre que
ce système financier je pense a été
complexifié à dessin de telle manière
à rendre les gens en fait c'est toujours
la meilleure manière de créer de la
fatigue dans une société et de pas
soulever aussi les foules c'est de
rendre quelque chose d'incompréhensible
de très opaque et moi mon rôle et je
pense que la bataille culturelle qu'on
mène on est quand même en train de la
gagner parce que ce qui se passe dans le
système et en train de nous prouver que
tout ce qu'on dénonce est une est une
réalité que ce qu'on dénonce en fait
n'est pas On n'est pas que au nom d'une
utopie on est aussi au nom de la
stabilité et de la prospérité de nos
états et ça c'était un peu le problème
culturel c'est à dire qu'il y avait le
milieu financier traditionnel classique
qui disait bah nous en fait on sert on
sert la croissance des états on sert la
croissance des entreprises et en fait on
se rend compte de quoi on se rend compte
de quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui une
entreprise par exemple quand elle va en
bourse elle perd elle perd 40% de sa
capacité d'innovation que finalement
l'argent n'est plus investi dans
l'économie réelle l'essentiel de
l'argent fonctionne en vasclos c'est à
dire sur les 400 000 milliards dont je
vous ai parlé du système financier c'est
90 milliards qui qui correspond au PIB
c'est bien que finalement il y a une
déconnexion totale entre le système
financier qui qui s'est développé un peu
en vasclos c'est à dire que dans les
depuis à peu près 30 ans il y a eu un
bon en termes de création de nouveaux
produits financiers donc en fait
finalement l'essentiel des produits
financiers aujourd'hui sont plutôt des
produits financiers sur les marchés
secondaires c'est-à-dire sur la sur des
marchés d'échanges des places de marché
de vente et de rachat d'action donc ces
places de marché là correspondant à peu
près 3/4 du secteur financier quel type
de place de marché là les marchés
secondaires c'est
non en fait je vous parle
absolument donc c'est plus un jargon
moins technique qui qualifie qui
qualifie qui qualifie effectivement ce
qui est opaque mais en fait aujourd'hui
si vous voulez quand vous regardez par
exemple les produits d'assurance vie
prenons l'épargne française c'est assez
ça nous permet de comprendre à peu près
comment fonctionne l'épargne mondiales
et comment l'argent est placé les peines
françaises c'est objet de donner des
conseils je répète encore une fois non
non je n'étais pas en train de faire des
conseils là vraiment j'étais en train de
juste de vous décrypter comment
fonctionne le secteurs financiers vous
avez 6000 à 6000 milliards à peu près
5800 quelque chose donc en France
sur ces 5000 et quelques la plus grosse
part c'est l'assurance vie donc c'est à
peu près plus de 1000 milliards quelque
chose c'est sur des obligations d'État
donc sur la signature
pourquoi l'assurance vie a été créée
pourquoi c'est garantie par les
assureurs etc parce que ça permettait
aussi d'avoir une grosse partie de fonds
souveraines aujourd'hui c'est moins de
50% des produits des fonds euros qui
sont réellement placés dans le souverain
parce que le souverain est beaucoup
moins rentable et permettait pas de
rendre les produits d'assurance vie
assez attractif donc ils ont mis
d'autres choses des actions d'entreprise
des obligations d'entreprise ils ont
racheté des unités de compte etc et mais
il y a toujours beaucoup de souverains
l'assurance vie soutient quand même
beaucoup encore le souverain aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs le problème actuel
sachant que c'est les assureurs qui
garantissent les produits d'assurance
vie il y a quand même un sujet autour de
du taux notamment de l'action et en fait
dans les assurances vie vous avez une
grosse partie d'unité de compte ou
d'action ou d'obligation dans les unités
de compte c'est essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle des et alors les ETF qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est de la duplication
finalement de portefeuille donc par
exemple CAC 40 etc et l'essentiel des
ETF c'est sur les marchés secondaires
donc en fait c'est du rachat d'actions
sur une place financière donc vous avez
une action disons totale
arrive à me laisser plus le nom
d'arriver Danone je sais pas vous
revendez
ou autre les gestionnaires d'actifs qui
vous vendent les produits
vont acheter revendre des actions et du
coup l'essentiel en fait des placements
qui sont faits sur l'épargne sont par
vesti finalement dans les entreprises
ils sont plutôt ils servent à garantir
la liquidité du système sauf que ce qui
était quelque chose à l'origine qui
était plutôt plutôt désirable dans le
sens où ça rendait liquides le
financement de l'entreprise la création
de ces marchés secondaires et
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui en fait
prend beaucoup trop de place dans le
secteur financier et fait que les
entreprises n'arrivent pas notamment à
lever des fonds pour investir dans
l'activité économique et notamment dans
la transition écologique qui est un gros
sujet aujourd'hui si on regarde les
investissements à transition écologique
de représentants que 4% des
investissements mondiaux donc à l'air ou
le dernier rapport du GIEC est sorti
lundi
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
concernant il est même pas question de
dire est-ce que l'écologie et
l'investissement écologique doit
remplacer entièrement mais à minima
avoir une place significative dans les
investissements quand on aura déjà
dépassé les 30% on pourra être assuré
c'est quand même
interpellant le fait que ce soit que 4%
alors que toute la journée
on voit
canicule à gauche inondations à droite
le Pakistan sous les sous la flotte
sécheresse hivernale
déplacement de migrants à cause de la
saturation d'humidité de température
comment ça se fait quel est votre
lecture sur le fait que ce soit que 4 %
parce que ça rapporte pas parce que les
banques ont rien à faire parce que s'il
y a pas assez de rendement pour
maintenir leur activité c'est quoi c'est
la pressurisation des actionnaires pour
récupérer un max de dividende ou un max
de rendement quel est votre lecture sur
ces que 4%
l'investissement sur la dans la
transition écologique vous imaginez que
pour transformer une boîte une énorme
boîte aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet encore assez compliqué en
terme de transformation
on peut on peut trouver des choses
intéressantes tenant apprenant un
secteur je trouve qui me j'arriverai
plus à imager de par mes connaissances
également le secteur de l'alimentation
par exemple
ou de la cour écologie mais donc dans le
secteur d'alimentation transformer une
entreprise qui aujourd'hui distribue
l'essentiel de ces produits qui vont
être du coup consommés manger dans des
petites boîtes en plastique
utilisant des
une agriculture qui est pas une
agriculture qui respecte les sols
importants une grande partie également
de sa production
utilisant des OGM peut-être dans
certains dans certains pays pour pouvoir
développer des cultures
industrialisant
industrialisant typiquement la
consommation carnée vous imaginez le
chantier que c'est pour transformer une
boîte comme ça et donc ça peut aider à
faire pousser les tomates dans le désert
je dirais d'une façon très triviale
est-ce qu'on considère que du coup c'est
écologique de de faire pousser des
tomates dans le désert moi je ne pense
pas justement en fait l'enjeu il est
préservé il est préservé notre
biodiversité en tout cas ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que pour transformer une
boîte comme ça ça prend du temps et
aujourd'hui l'investissement il est
massivement court terme parce qu'il y a
cette recherche de liquidité à court
terme parce qu'on a une industrie qui
s'est construite avec des personnes qui
travaillent dans cette industrie et qui
sont là pour faire ce travail de
réaliser des actions des de réaliser des
opérations financières quotidiennement
que pour créer un marché liquide et ben
il faut effectivement que l'entreprise
soit capable de verser des dividendes
annuels et on n'est pas dans le temps
long on n'est pas même dans le moyen
terme donc c'est le problème principal
pour lequel le secteur financier ne
change pas c'est qui dans une il ne
fonctionne que sur du court terme la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il est opaque
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut même pas
savoir s'il est particulier parce que ce
qu'on dit pas c'est que 87% quand même
de la finance mondiale c'est les fonds
de pension c'est quoi votre source c'est
quoi ma source alors waouh sur ça je
vous l'enverrai parce que je suis désolé
c'est compliqué de revenir tous les
rapports mais alors en fait le truc
c'est que j'ai la source parce que j'ai
posé ça avec notre base de données donc
en fait rift mon activité c'est de
travailler sur des bases de données donc
de recomposer la data de l'ensemble des
produits d'Epargne et de savoir qui gère
l'ensemble de l'épargne et ensuite du
coup quels sont les acteurs donc là je
vous disais les fonds de pension nos 87%
sont identifié c'est que ce sont des
fonds de pension donc c'est des boîtes
d'assurance si vous voulez ou des
banques qui vont gérer de l'épargne
l'épargne pour des individus
donc finalement et c'est à peu près 4%
qui sont des personnes physiques et 14%
des familles qui détiennent notamment
les entreprises donc quand même on a 87%
de fonds de pension sur la totalité des
400 000 milliards et des fonds de
pension c'est quoi finalement c'est
l'épargne des individus donc c'est
indirectement la population compilée
quoi
et donc si jamais
les gens avaient accès réellement à la
manière dont leur épargne était allouée
et qu'il comprenait réellement les
investissements qui étaient faits et qui
pouvaient avoir un peu de pouvoir dessus
on pourrait penser que une démocratie
pour exister en finance dans la mesure
où les décisions qui sont prises avec
l'argent des individus elles sont prises
avec les individus elles sont pris sans
les consulter donc imaginons qu'on ait
une démocratie dans le secteur financier
s'il y a un mouvement imaginons parce
que c'est moi c'est mon je me projette
dans des
utopies transformations et c'est ce à
quoi je j'aspire c'est de créer une
transparence dans le secteur financier
pour que en fait finalement quand une
grosse partie de la population considère
que la transition écologique et que le
changement climatique et la
préoccupation principale et ben ils
exigent de leur gestionnaire d'actifs
ils exigent de leur banque ils exigent
de leur société d'assurance qu'elles
investissent différemment donc les deux
problèmes voilà c'est le court thermiste
pour moi et l'opacité si on est dans une
objective un optique plus long terme et
qu'on rend accessible l'information je
pense que des gens pour augmenter ce
taux c'est pour ça que vous avez fait
des études
de psychologie des philosophie
philosophie pardon c'est pour comprendre
la psyché des gens que vous aviez en
face c'est pour donner aussi un sens
métaphysique à ce que je faisais
essentiellement est-ce que la
philosophie en tout cas sur le secteur
financier m'a beaucoup appris c'est la
question de comment on crée la
responsabilité moi ce qui m'intéresse
aussi absolument c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui
quand on a un produit financier alors
que les gens commencent à comprendre que
les boîtes qu'ils ont-ils dénoncent les
actions tous les jours sont bien
financées par quelque chose et doit
directement par l'épargne et par les
banques pourquoi malgré tout bon bah
disons que
ils n'ont pas conscience justement ça a
encore plus de sens il y a un philosophe
qui s'appelle Levinas Emmanuel Levinas
qui dit que le mois devant autrui est
infiniment responsable c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous créez vous
mettez un visage sur l'action finalement
vous créez un phénomène de
responsabilité pour l'autre et dans le
secteur financier on voit bien que bah
il est tellement sur intermédié ce
secteur il est tellement opaque que la
personne qui souscrit un produit ne voit
pas le visage ne sait pas ce qu'il fait
ne qu'on n'a pas conscience des dégâts
qu'il produit à travers son épargne et
finalement c'est ça aussi que la
philosophie m'a un peu appris ce qu'elle
m'a appris aussi un auteur qui m'a
passionné qui s'appelle Gunta unders qui
a un auteur allemand qui a comparé alors
c'est sur une toute autre industrie mais
c'est très intéressant qui a comparé
l'irresponsabilité au moment de de la
Shoah et l'irresponsabilité de certaines
parties prenantes sur le secteur
nucléaire donc c'était une autre époque
c'est dur mais c'est sur le fait que
chacun ait une toute petite part de
responsabilité qui ne finit personne est
responsable c'est ça si je résume très
également chose de une c'est ça et de
deux ce que ça ce que sa philosophie
elle elle permet de montrer c'est que
au-delà du fait que la responsabilité
est divisée c'est pas le seul problème
le problème c'est qu'on crée des
machines des méga machine qui
surintermédient
et qui laisse apparaître le monstrueux
c'est à dire que lui ce qu'il dit c'est
que le monstrueux ne peut apparaître que
quand en fait on a une méga machine que
quand on a une sur intermédiation telle
que la responsabilité est impossible
parce qu'elle est tellement sur
intermédiaire et que finalement
l'essentiel de la société c'est ça c'est
des gens qui sont sur intermédié qui
sont un peu victimes de l'opacité de la
méga machine il y a quelques déciseurs
donc il compare avec Eichmann en fait
pour lui Eichmann est un décideur
là je vous parle dans la dans dans ce
qu'il dans la manière dont il décrypte
ce qui s'est passé pendant la Shoah
c'est qu'il dit qu'il y a eu des
décideurs comme Eichmann qui ont
organisé ce système cette méga machine
qui a eu des gens qui se sont des
responsabilisés et que ça allait laisser
le monstrueux exister c'est ce qu'il dit
je suis pas d'accord avec tout mais en
tout cas laisser ce qu'il dit et il
compare avec le fait que à partir du
moment où on crée une industrie
tellement grande on laisse place aux
monstrueux donc il y a des personnes qui
sont conscients mais l'essentiel de la
société et même les gens surtout
l'essentiel des gens qui travaillent
dans des institutions financières très
honnêtement ils sont pas acteurs du
monstrueux ils organisent la méga
machine après c'est dur le parallèle que
vous faites
moi je vous parle de philosophie ce que
la philosophie m'a appris maintenant si
on regarde aujourd'hui le secteur
financier il y a une méga machine c'est
clair c'est un écosystème énorme
il y a une action les banquiers sont pas
tous des gens qui veulent
ils sont pas tous méchants moi je
travaille beaucoup de banquiers
d'ailleurs parce que pas pour développer
mes boîtes on lève des fonds voilà on
fait des on a des crédits et puis on a
envie on nous on travaille dans le
dialogue avec le système financier moi
je connais les banquiers il y en a il y
en a une part d'entre eux qui ont envie
de changer le système il y a une part
d'entre eux qui font leur activité
prêteur dans l'économie réelle c'est à
dire qu'ils sont en contact avec des
gens qui ont des besoins et prêtes il y
a des une part d'entre eux
on va parler de ça ouais absolument ah
bah oui bien sûr on va en parler tout de
suite
on va en parler dans cinq minutes
et il y a effectivement des gens qui
sont dans des salles de marché et qui et
qui travaille en fait la finance comme
des mathématiques comme de l'algorithmie
et même ces gens-là ils ont pas
conscience de ce qui crée ils ont pas
conscience quand quand on investissant
une valeur ou un des investissant une
valeur ils vont créer une crise
économique ici une famille ailleurs etc
en tout cas le problème dans tout ça
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas prendre
conscience de ça ils ne veulent pas voir
le visage et c'est ça qu'on pourrait
leur dire limiter ça qu'on pourrait leur
opposer à ces gens-là c'est pas d'être
des gens qui qui laissent exister
monstrueux c'est des gens qui ne veulent
pas voir et je pense que l'essentiel du
monde financier c'est ça vous êtes sûr
qu'ils veulent pas voir
pourquoi ils veulent pas voir c'est ici
ils sont sur leur écran et qui font pas
le cheminement de où ça va par exemple
quelqu'un qui investit sur des valeurs
Millières il sera ils seront peut-être
pas compte que à la fin il y a la
pollution dans la rivière du gamin qui
va à l'école donc il peut plus boire
l'eau de la rivière et puis comme il y a
pas de canalisation tu peux pas boire
l'eau du robinet et puis l'eau du
robinet elle est contaminée vous avez
discuté avec ces acteurs de marché
absolument et qu'est-ce qui vous disent
ces gens-là
les investissements de cette banque pour
avoir une investissement plus éthique
sur le domaine du nuclé et sur le
domaine du
la pâte à papier le charbon
effectivement donc cette expérience en
banque c'est si ça qui me permet
aujourd'hui d'être aussi dans une
posture de dialogue avec le secteur
bancaire parce que j'ai été un peu de
l'intérieur après moi ça fait combien de
temps combien de temps j'ai fait là-bas
j'ai fait 6 mois ok donc c'était très
très court j'ai travaillé sur
effectivement les désinvestissements
dans les secteurs les plus controversés
comme l'huile de palme l'armement le
nuclé la pâte à papier etc
c'est effectivement aujourd'hui
une industrie qui est plus valorisée que
dévaloriser à l'époque moi c'était
l'industrie sur lesquels la société
civile vous la tout prix que la banque
c'est ses investissements c'est très
civile mais
peut-être Dr qui était là pour le coup
la raison pour laquelle la banque non
non vous avez raison la raison pour
laquelle la banque mettait en place
qu'on appelle des politiques
sectorielles c'est à dire que sur les
grands secteurs les plus controversés
elle mettait en place des politiques
pour savoir quand est-ce qu'on pouvait
faire et quand est-ce qu'on pouvait pas
faire donc par exemple faire de l'huile
de palme quand ça déforestait et que il
y avait pas de de capacité de mise en
place de capacité pour pouvoir régénérer
les sols ça en fait pas une centrale ça
me donne sismique on fait pas enfin des
trucs comme ça ça c'est vraiment le truc
un peu caricaturé et ensuite c'était
beaucoup plus fin et je m'appelle même
de certains dossiers dans l'industrie
nucléaire parce que l'industrie
nucléaire le problème on parle beaucoup
de problèmes de radioactivité etc moi
j'ai vu aussi beaucoup de problèmes au
niveau de l'extraction il y a eu
certains dossiers qui ont pas été fait
pourquoi parce que je sais pas si vous
avez vous connaissez il me ramène au
Niger par exemple donc c'est quoi c'est
donc c'est l'extraction d'uranium fait
dans des conditions de travail
déplorables ou les personnes qui
travaillent dans l'industrie dans la
mine sont traités
je dis ce que j'ai vu ce que la banque
m'a donné même demandé de voir à
l'époque donc le terrain non j'avais pas
j'ai pas eu l'occasion d'aller sur le
terrain la manière dont on nourrissait
c'est effectivement les rapports photos
vidéos des ONG etc de toute façon il y a
peu qui pourront vous dire que
l'extraction d'uranium et nous ramène
c'est plutôt bien fait un très
raisonnement ça se fait plutôt consensus
la question c'est ensuite est-ce qu'on
continue de faire ou pas donc il y a
l'extraction qui est problématique il y
a aussi des quatre cancers qui ont été
non déclarés par l'entreprise en
question il y a aussi le partage de la
valeur avec l'État qui a été
effectivement sous-évalué des
compensations extrêmement faibles enfin
bref déchets radioactifs balancés
différents dans différentes régions etc
garage africain machin donc nous on a vu
ça et en gros c'était la manière dont on
voyait effectivement aussi les déboires
de cette industrie là donc
j'ai pas du tout une posture contre
le nucléaire ou même contre l'extraction
certains minerais qui sont nécessaires
typiquement pour la transition
écologique il va y avoir besoin de
certaines minerais maintenant
il faut s'intéresser à la filière on va
pas faire de l'extraction comme on
faisait hier et aujourd'hui il me le
problème c'est que personne ne
s'intéresse réellement à la filière et à
la responsabilisation la socialisation
de cette filière donc elle est pro
nucléaire qui vous disent génial c'est
énergie du futur ça va résoudre tous nos
problèmes moi pour tout
dégarnéaires qui nous disent oui oui les
mixeurs à chouette c'est vachement bien
les panneaux solaires c'est vachement
bien et ainsi de suite donc il y a pas
de consensus entre les deux c'est ça je
trouve que en fait le il y a un truc un
peu trop dans l'énergie sur l'énergie
nucléaire un peu trop genre ça va
épouser tous nos problèmes
bien sûr qu'il va on a besoin de
nucléaire
y compris dans les années c'est à dire
dans les énergies renouvelables c'est
non je trouve que pour le coup les
défenses les défendeurs de l'énergie des
énergies renouvelables sont quand même
un peu plus
enfin il défendent aussi des politiques
de sobriété il défendent aussi des
politiques de réduction de nos émissions
globales je trouve que dans côté
nucléaire parfois il y a cette idée
qu'on va tout électrifier et que tout
ira mieux
ils disent pas on va tout on va tout
électrifier avec les énergies il faut
une politique fin personnellement c'est
plutôt les écologistes qui sont
défenseurs de la progression massive des
énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui en
tout cas en France dans beaucoup
d'autres pays je vais vous dire le
nucléaire
moi je vous parle pas de du coup du CO2
aujourd'hui c'est je vous parle de la
question de l'extraction je parle de la
question de est-ce que le projet
écologique c'est remettre des centrales
et des énormes machins partout dans les
dans les dans les pays qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par énorme
oui bon maintenant on essaie de
construire des petits plus petits trucs
absolument mais en fait je pense que la
construction en soi des centrales n'est
pas ça veut dire que c'est vertueux pour
la transition de nos économies et pour
l'atteindre d'un scénario à 1,5 degrés
durée de vie donc déjà c'est pas
nécessairement c'est pas c'est pas
évident visiblement mais on en a pas
encore en fait moi je voulais ça et moi
je vois je crois que ce que je ne vois
je vois que quand on produit des
énergies renouvelables ça crée de
l'énergie quand on met des centrales pas
toujours voilà très honnêtement qu'il y
a un gros problème aussi sur les métiers
qui a un gros problème sur cette
industrie etc donc c'est une partie de
la solution comme les renouvelables sont
une plus grosse partie de la solution et
puis l'autre partie de la solution c'est
surtout avoir une économie qui est moins
dépendante à la création d'énergie et
c'est ça alors je sais moi ça que
j'appelle à créer aujourd'hui avec les
différents mouvements etc c'est une et
l'économie qui n'est plus qui est plus
dépendre moins dépendante aux énergies
fossiles pour des questions de CO2 pour
des questions transition écologique mais
aussi pour des questions géopolitiques
et je vous écoute maintenant je peux
prendre la parole bien sûr
je me détends un peu ce que je veux dire
pour revenir pour revenir au nucléaire à
la dépendance et à l'énergie
l'économie c'est pas un vecteur
énergétique simplement les marchés
financiers c'est pas un vecteur
énergétique est-ce que si on diminue si
on rentre en décroissance est-ce que
l'économie va pas morfler est-ce que
pour revenir à votre envie de
transformer le système financier de
transformer la psychée de ceux qui sont
aux manettes
ils vous ont pas regardé on dirait
écoutez ma petite dame je suis d'accord
avec vous mais mais derrière ça va être
créé tellement de perturbations que ça
va faire cale enchaîner cette boîte là
créer du chômage là ça va kancher sur un
pays est-ce que ça risque d'amener
beaucoup de problèmes alors vous leur
répondez mais si on se change pas les
problèmes climatiques correspondent sur
la tête sont infiniment plus importants
alors comme il résonne à court terme il
voit les problèmes tout de suite
si on baisse notre consommation
énergétique est-ce que les systèmes
financiers vont pouvoir résister
la finance elle s'adapte la finance
c'est la colonne vertébrale aujourd'hui
on a une économie effectivement qui ne
croit que sur la croissance des énergies
fossiles on a une économie qui n'est pas
régénérative donc il ne permet pas du
coup de plutôt avoir un impact positif
sur l'environnement demain l'objectif
est que les financiers participent à
financer une économie qui régénérative
participe à financer une économie aussi
qui est moins lourde en consommation
c'est à dire que typiquement l'économie
du soin disons c'est de l'économie du
soin si vous voulez
aller à l'hosto vous dites que c'est la
bobo de l'économie non je l'économie du
soin c'est c'est tout ça
justement parce que les choix financiers
les choix économiques qu'on fait ne sont
pas les bons donc justement si on change
de lunettes c'est à dire on essaie de
regarder l'économie selon ce qu'elle
apporte concrètement aux gens parce que
c'est pas notre système financier enfin
dans le quoi qu'il en coûte une certaine
manière oui mais c'est pas le système
qui nous a vraiment aidés en crise par
le covid etc ce qui nous a aidé c'est
notre c'est la solidarité de notre
système c'est l'hôpital public c'est ça
aurait été si on avait pu des capacités
productives c'est les effectivement tous
les salariés et les travailleurs de
première ligne donc c'est tous ces
métiers et en cascade c'est toutes
l'économie de ces métiers là qui doit
être aujourd'hui accompagné et aider
davantage donc c'est sûr que l'économie
elle va elle doit changer et le système
financier financera ce à quoi
ressemblera l'économie demain donc il
financera soit à quoi le transport
ressemblera demain il financera ce à
quoi l'industrie ressemblera demain etc
mais c'est sûr qu'on va avoir moins
d'énergie
l'inertie de ces 100 dernières années
non le système échange vite on a
l'impression que le système capitaliste
financier on a l'impression que c'est un
truc qui date de il y a 300 ans alors
que c'est hyper récent au final la
financiarisation elle date des années 90
pourquoi il y a pas de régulation il y a
quand même de la régulation c'est ce qui
fait quand même que aujourd'hui en
France nos banques par rapport aux
banques américaines elles sont un peu
plus régulier protégée et tout
quand même si on peut rentrer dans le
détail de baltringue
ils ont juste un petit Bob pour le coup
de soleil quand même vu les montants
engagés en face on est d'accord non le
fond de garantie des beaux bancaires
français c'est quoi c'est combien de
milliards
c'est la manière dont la gestion d'actif
aussi en France qui est pas du tout la
même cause us il y a beaucoup moins de
produits pourris dans les banques
françaises dans les banques américaines
des banques d'affaires et des banques de
marché
des banques de dépôt et des banques
d'investissement des banques d'affaires
aujourd'hui il y a une séparation c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui avec les dépôts en
France ils peuvent prêter
ensuite il y a des banques
d'investissement il y a des groupes
bancaires aussi donc vous avez des
banques de dépôt qui sont des filiales
vous avez des banques d'investissement
qui sont des filiales vous avez des
sociétés d'assurance qui sont des
filiales de ces grands groupes bancaires
mais il y a une muraille de Chine
aujourd'hui on ne va pas vous vendre des
titres en direct et on va pas placer vos
dépôts dans des titres en direct ça
en tout cas on peut pas le faire
vous non le système bancaire français et
tant mieux en fait tant mieux parce que
du coup c'est pas les mêmes modèles
économiques la banque d'investissement
n'a pas le modèle économique la banque
de dépôt etc donc normalement avec les
dépôts des gens on peut prêter on peut
il y a une partie qui est placée en
bilan bancaire global
dans ce bilan bancaire vous avez aussi
effectivement la prise de participation
mais vous avez aussi beaucoup de dettes
souveraines c'est un truc qui est plutôt
équilibré etc donc il y a moins de
problèmes ce qui s'est passé aux US en
fait Bruno Le Maire c'est ce qu'il a dit
c'est ce qu'il a dit pardon je dis pas
c'est ce que Bruno Le Maire a dit
effectivement aux investisseurs pourquoi
il a dit calme down
là où je suis d'accord avec lui c'est
que c'est rare c'est très rare mais
c'est que effectivement
donc là quand il dit canne down une
certaine manière il a raison pourquoi
parce que le principal virus du système
financier c'est la question de la manque
de confiance comment absolument la
propagation de la c'est évident et le
cas du crédit suis c'est le cas de la
Silicone Valley banque sont deux cas
tout à fait différents ce qu'ils ont en
commun c'est la peur dans le cas de la
Silicon Valley manque moi ce que je
trouve marrant il va essayer qu'on
devait aller banques c'est pas marrant
du tout ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
fait ça montre moins les défaillances du
système bancaire bien sûr que les
hypothèses qui sont le fait que les taux
de la pension très longue augmentée donc
les investissements de la Silicon Valley
banque qui sont essentiellement du
souverain étaient trop faible etc
ça c'est une réalité bancaire mais ce
qui est le plus principalement car la
Silicon valley-banque c'est que c'est
une banque de start-up qui fonctionnait
comme une start-up et une startup c'est
quoi le principe d'une start-up
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que des boîtes
d'air qui sont un peu moins start-up
nation que comme les miennes
c'est comme si tu réussissais jusqu'à ce
que tu réussisses vraiment
jusqu'à ce que tu les fais c'est ça
aussi on fait comme si quoi
comme vous préférez l'entendre le
problème d'asticot Valley banque pour
moi c'est que c'était un modèle start-up
c'est à dire qu'il avait un modèle de
fonctionnement trop simple trop simple
ils ont pas diversifié c'est à dire que
les dépôts de la Silicon valley-banque
c'était que des startups que des
startups de la Silicon Valley donc il y
a une crise de la Silicon Valley parce
qu'il y a eu un moment où les elles ont
levé beaucoup beaucoup d'oseille il y a
eu une crise donc elles ont besoin
plutôt de dépenser cet oseille donc de
réduire leur dépôt donc la silicone va
les banques elle avait moins de dépôt
donc elle avait besoin de vendre ses
titres et elle avait pas diversifié non
plus donc elle avait que des titres des
mondes du Trésor donc pour moi c'est et
parce que c'était simple et en plus
usage simple on peut sortir son oseille
comme ça en soi et Pan donc beaucoup de
gens ont voulu ont eu un peu peur et du
coup ils ont sorti leur argent donc
c'était il y avait moins les grandes
queues qu'on a pu connaître dans les
années 30 etc
les dirigeants
Silicon Valley banque ah ça par contre
j'ai pas été attentive j'ai pas vu s'ils
ont ils se sont protégés eux-mêmes en
tout cas
je sais pas ça je sais pas je vais vous
dire si dans les quatre faillites les
dirigeants partent avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent j'ai moins de j'avoue
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'infos par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est que là il y a eu une
peur il y a eu un phénomène de peur ou
en fait ils ont réalisé que les titres
étaient sous-évalués que Silicon Valley
banque avait moins de moins de dépôts et
que la banque était en crise et ça c'est
un gros problème de manque de
diversification en termes de clients en
termes d'investissement etc on peut pas
tout miser sur un marché surtout un
marché qui est quand même hyper instable
le marché de la start-up de la tech et
des super instable il évolue sur les
périodes il y a des bulles tout le temps
ça fait partie du deal quoi entre
guillemets c'est à dire
le risque est pas rémunérateur quand en
fait vous ne gérez que les dépôts en soi
bon oui il est terminé
plein de dépôts à l'époque où les
startups fonctionnaient super bien donc
c'est bien ça les a fait grandir très
vite et alors que c'est une toute petite
banque elle sait il sait à la 16e place
des banques américaines donc c'est c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas mal pour
une petite banque à l'origine mais bon
en cas de crise voilà ce qui s'est passé
au Crédit Suisse c'est entièrement
différent
c'est c'est le même principe de la
confiance de la peur qui a neutralisé
mais c'est qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au
Crédit Suisse et eu un problème de
contrôle interne une faille de contrôle
interne un truc voilà qui est vraiment
lié plutôt contrôle interne qui sont
conformités
qui a une faille dans le contrôle après
ce qui avait vraiment derrière les gens
savaient pas trop donc justement aussi
le fait de pas être trop transparent
parfois ça ça peut encore plus faire
flipper les gens alors que si on leur
dit aussi bah c'est
comme essaie de le faire certains
certaines acteurs bancaires c'est une
période d'économie se stabilise etc bon
en tout cas et cette feuille de contrôle
interne donc il y a un investisseur ça
ou bien qu'il détenait une grosse partie
qui a dit que il réinvestirait pas dans
le Crédit Suisse et du coup tout le
monde a flippé et ça a amené voilà
comment
fasse le deal un dimanche avec le
gouvernement suisse qui poussait fort
derrière
c'était pourquoi éviter la contagion
c'est vrai que j'ai pas fait le lien
avec le fait que c'était un dimanche
pour être tout à fait honnête est-ce que
ça a été fait aussi là parce que les
gens étaient moins attentifs
effectivement à ce qui se passait les
marchés étaient fermés en soirée ils ont
toujours ouvert mais les salles de
marché et les gens étaient pas dans la
salle de marché donc il se passait moins
un truc et ça montre que il y a un
moment dans des situations comme ça de
crise il faut réguler et nous avons la
MF l'a fait pendant covid la MF en covid
elle s'est dit waouh ce qui va se passer
sur les marchés c'est que tout le monde
va parier à la baisse sur les boîtes ça
va mettre l'économie hein
la MFC dit pendant la crise du covid
tout le monde a parié à la baisse sur
les valeurs ça va mettre l'économie dans
une situation déplorable on va empêcher
certaines opérations de se faire
le même moment ils se sont fait aussi un
peu de pognon non les gens qui vendent
qui parient à la baisse justement la MF
a voulu que ces opérations se fassent le
moins possible pour qu'ils ont calmé
tout le monde ils ont calmé ils ont
derrière on est derrière on autorise
plus ce type de placement pendant tel et
je rentre tel et telle période c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire pendant
une crise financière et c'est exactement
ce que aujourd'hui qui est pas accepté
sur les marchés c'est cueillait des
régulateurs puissants alors que pour moi
c'est quelque chose qui peut apporter
beaucoup de stabilité à ce secteur et
que tant qu'il est pas régulé
malheureusement il restera instable en
France on a la chance qu'il le soit
beaucoup
stable
bien sûr il se passe des trucs sur les
marchés là il y a eu des gros problèmes
etc mais en tout cas le fait qu'il soit
régulé c'est ça qui participe quand même
à sa stabilité et si il était moins les
marchés financiers français enfin en
tout cas dans le milieu bancaire pardon
français serait beaucoup moins serait
beaucoup moins stable et on verrait des
crises pop-up comme ça
il y a encore beaucoup de choses à
améliorer moi je trouve que la question
du financement direct de l'économie
réelle ça qui était une des conclusions
de la crise de 2008 Thierry philippona
qui a été quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup
écouté quand j'étais justement dans la
banque etc et que j'essaie de penser la
finance de demain qui parlait justement
de ce problème de d'allocation des
liquidités vers l'économie réelle qui
faisait qu'on a un système financier qui
ne fonctionne que par lui-même donc
quand le système fonctionne mal le
système peut être érosif toute tout seul
quoi l'économie réelle peut bien se
porter mais le système peut déconner
donc il faut essayer de recréer des
circuits financiers plus dirigés vers
l'économie réelle ça malheureusement je
pense enfin si on regarde les chiffres
en tout cas il n'y a pas une progression
massive de la part qui est dans
l'économie réelle est beaucoup plus
voilà les actifs financiers prennent une
place trop importante par contre ce que
la crise de 2008 quand même a permis
c'est une présence plus forte des
régulateurs des ratios de fonds propres
plus élevés une séparation plus forte
des activités d'investissement et des
activités de dépôt et de crédit
et une sensibilisation aussi globale
massive des gens sur le fait qu'il faut
arrêter de faire n'importe sur les
marchés n'importe quoi pardon aussi je
parle naturellement il faut arrêter de
faire n'importe quoi et du coup ça ça
pollinisé aussi la manière dont
fonctionner les les gens qui
investissent quoi donc dans les dans le
West management donc management c'est le
département des banques pour gérer les
gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent
et ces gens là ils ont un peu plus de
pouvoir dans le système financier
peuvent décider un peu plus comment sont
alloués leur placement beaucoup moins
que derrière c'est ce que ce combat
aussi au quotidien beaucoup moins que le
retail ça veut dire monsieur et madame
tout le monde ceux qui ont des
patrimoine
comme vous et moi peut-être qu'il y a
des gens qui ont plus d'argent mais moi
j'ai pas beaucoup j'ai pas vraiment
d'argent donc moi je suis en retail quoi
sauf que maintenant moi j'investis seul
j'investis à mon côté etc c'est pas
forcément toujours une bonne stratégie
voilà
et ces gens-là ils ont des produits
ultra packagés donc ils peuvent pas
décider vraiment comment y passer leur
argent donc je vous coupe avant que vous
me
développiez un petit peu votre boîte
votre lecture sur la politique de Ben
perdant qu'en 2008 et de son prix Nobel
du moins de son prix d'économie je peux
pas vous répondre
le fait d'avoir injecté des liquidités
attaquées
pour plus récemment sont très
globalement sur l'injection des
liquidités
moi je
veux dire que on sait que ça se passe
comme ça je veux dire aujourd'hui la
création monétaire le système de la
création monétaire et la question
l'attribution de crédit n'est possible
que par le fait que la banque centrale
injecte 90% des liquidités quand on vous
fait un crédit c'est 10% à peu près en
moyenne d'argent de la banque 90% de
création monétaire
ça en soi moi j'ai pas de difficulté si
tentais que c'est une politique
monétaire qui est ciblée
aujourd'hui elle est pas ciblée c'est à
dire que ces créations monétaires
indifféremment l'hélicoptère d'argent
c'est ça on balance l'argent un peu
n'importe où n'importe comment en tout
cas on sélectionne pas c'est à dire que
on crée la monnaie quand il y a un
besoin d'un crédit mais on dit pas tel
type de projet on crée la monnaie tel
type de projet on crée pas de monnaie
donc pourquoi ils ont quand ils ont
injecté des liquidités ils savaient bien
que le GIEC il commençait à s'énerver
dans leur petit bureau que on avait pris
longtemps pourquoi pourquoi ils ont pas
dit bon bah c'est une bonne idée alors
certes on a fait plusieurs régulations
c'était une bonne idée pourquoi ils ont
pas dit ok ben non c'est la transition
écologique la transition énergétique et
était un petit peu respectueux pourquoi
ils l'ont pas fait à votre avis
alors pour plusieurs raisons déjà parce
qu'ils avaient besoin de conduire ce
qu'on appelle les stress test
climatiques
est-ce que c'est mené à peu près comme
une stress bancaire
c'était mené par la Banque centrale
européenne sous la direction et
l'impulsion Christine Lagarde pour dire
aux acteurs financiers on va évaluer si
vous êtes préparé ou pas au risque
physique et climatique que vos
portefeuilles financiers vont en courir
mais c'est intéressant c'est une diplôme
c'est la diplomatie intéressante c'est à
dire qu'elle va pas en amont dire vous
êtes tous casser la gueule elle dit on
va évaluer parce que elle a réalisé
parce que il serait test climatiques à
elle mais qu'est-ce que les stress test
climatiques sur les banques européennes
ont réalisé c'est que les banques se
sont pas adaptées elles sont pas prêtes
en fait et que 70% de leurs actifs sont
pas du tout adaptés à la transformation
que
qu'on va qu'on va nécessairement devoir
impulser parce qu'on va être dans tous
les cas exposés à des risques physiques
et climatiques donc sécheresse
inondations etc qui m'ont impacté
l'économie on est même pas dans
l'idéologie écologique là on est
vraiment sur juste l'économie va être
impactée
donc à partir du moment où elle a
conduit ça derrière ils ont pu conduire
donc en parallèle bien sûr
une politique qui s'oppose un peu au
projet européen le problème c'est que le
projet européen c'est basé c'est
l'Europe libérale c'est basé
l'Europe de la libre concurrence
c'est-à-dire que on ne donne pas les
règles au marché c'est le marché
européen qui va exister le rêve du
capital market union de l'Union des
marchés de capitaux c'est le projet
européen l'Europe libéral et du coup ce
projet là il empêchait beaucoup de
pouvoir mener des politiques monétaires
par exemple ciblées vertes parce qu'on
savait pas c'est quoi vert c'est quoi
vert est-ce qu'on autorise finalement à
créer une incitation sur une forme
d'économie et plutôt qu'une autre ça ça
s'oppose complètement au projet européen
donc là aujourd'hui maintenant vous avez
taxonomie machin etc donc des grosses
lois européennes pour essayer de définir
ce qui est vert et ce qui est pas vert
que vous avez les stress test
climatiques qui montrent que dans tous
les cas c'est une urgence que en plus
maintenant la Banque centrale européenne
c'est dotée comme mission également de
la stabilité climatique de l'Union
européenne ce qui est extrêmement rare
et ce qu'ils ont pu faire aussi parce
qu'ils ont réussi à vraiment faire cette
sensibilisation cette modélisation
globale que en plus qui maintenant a
rendu sa position encore plus claire
qu'avant c'est-à-dire que là il y a pas
de doute je pense qu'ils s'auto censure
d'ailleurs trop le geek je pense qu'il
saute au censure
j'ai lu les synthèses et ça donne quoi
ça donne c'est un truc qui que
si on continue à extraire
ne serait-ce que rien d'énergie fossile
du sol on est mort on dépasse 1,5 degrés
voilà déjà c'est que là aujourd'hui avec
ce qui ah bah dépasser 1,5 degrés c'est
quoi la conséquence
et vous projetez ah si ça des impact en
l'Union européenne ces impacts partout
mais je sais malheureusement
je vais pas essayer de vous sensibiliser
sur c'est quoi l'impact des deux et des
3 degrés
donc dans tous les cas voilà ça c'est le
plus bas dans je trouve parce que quand
on voit aujourd'hui les entreprises
énergétiques continuent à développer de
nouveaux projets d'extraction d'énergie
fossile il faut bien faire valider
en fait on veut la détruire on veut la
protéger l'économie enfin parce que
l'économie c'est juste l'organisation de
la société globalement donc à partir du
moment on a des vagues migratoires qu'on
a des des inondations sécheresses vécues
dans des pays qui qui crée un scénario
mortifère pour les pays d'ailleurs je
peux me permettre tout ce qu'on a pas
parlé de ce sujet mais j'aimerais en
parler la question de la dette
climatique parce que on a on a quand
même un enjeu ouais désolé mais c'est
quand même l'enjeu principal ici je
rappelle juste merci
9,5% 9,5 tonnes de CO2 consommé dans les
pays Europe États-Unis les pays d'y
développés
0,3 tonnes dans les pays dit pays du Sud
donc après bon vous avez des gens qui
sont à trois tonnes quand il se bat
beaucoup de moyens qui passent pas trop
vous avez des gens qui sont responsables
ils sont responsables des gens qui sont
voilà 45 ans quoi quand ils prennent
leur jet tout le temps quoi
[Musique]
absolument parce que en fait la
consommation carbonée plus vous avez
d'argent plus vous consommez plus vous
avez d'argent plus vous êtes vous êtes
vous avez besoin de surface donc quand
vous vous déplacez donc quand vous êtes
dans un avion vous l'êtes tout seul
quand vous voulez dans une voiture vous
voulez être tout seul quand vous êtes
enfin avec deux personnes mais quand
vous êtes dans un une maison vous êtes
peu avec une grande maison on peut le
chauffer enfin voilà c'est vraiment
calcule évident je pense que enfin il y
a pas de débat là-dessus malheureusement
il y a encore un débat c'est ça qui est
un peu bizarre dans la société
actuellement c'est impossible la plèbe
d'être avec eux c'est sans dents
pourquoi il voudrait être dans mon jet
privé je vous dirai
pourquoi qui voudrait d'un jet privé je
suis en train de caricaturer le riche
du reste du monde ah bah oui il ne
s'intéresse au reste du monde donc ce
que je vous dis la lamération
je me suis pas et d'ailleurs pardon
juste et 70% des gens qui vont vivre les
conséquences climatiques sont pour le
coup les gens qui consomment 0,3 donc
c'est évident alors je vais me faire la
moquette privée
un chef d'entreprise qui fait marcher
énormément l'économie il a besoin de se
déplacer du tac au tac il a besoin
d'aller serrer des pognes il a besoin
d'aller prendre un petit week-end quand
même à Hammamet parce que c'est reposant
et puis avec le stress qui le stress qui
peut avoir
dans un avion partagé avec d'autres gens
bon bref
écoutez en fait il faut réinventer il
faut réinventer effectivement le système
personne en fait au Delatour qui dit ça
c'est assez intéressant il dit que il
disait RIP ou atterrir Bruno Latour il
est décédé il y a pas longtemps un Slug
écologiste on peut l'appeler un peu
comme on veut mais il dit que la raison
pour laquelle il y a pas eu de mouvement
écologique dans la société c'est parce
que ceux qui décident pensait qu'il
pourrait être épargnés donc c'est un peu
finalement indirectement ce que vous
dites c'est à dire bon bah cette
personne elle peut être épargnée elle a
les moyens de s'adapter mais en fait on
se rend compte que non ça va transformer
la société donc c'est évident que non et
puis pour répondre à votre petite blague
sur est-ce qu'il est obligé d'aller
serrer des pinces ou les deux jours
on l'économie elle fonctionne très bien
sans que les patrons les grands patrons
n'en parle pas des patrons moi je suis
patron c'est ce qui me rend un peu
exotique
et d'ailleurs je trouve qu'il y a aussi
un quelque chose qui est instrumentalisé
aussi beaucoup l'image du patron alors
que l'essentiel des patrons c'est le
patron de PME patron de TI les gens qui
qui sait le faire qui bossent pour leurs
salariés enfin et en fait c'est un peu
volontaire aussi l'idée que bah on crée
une opposition à la société ce qui fait
que les patrons d'ailleurs ont du mal à
porter ces idées progressistes assez
c'est pour ça que le mousse que je fais
avec le mouvement pacte France je trouve
que c'est important il faut que les
syndicats patronaux donc on essaie de
créer une alternative au syndicat
patronal traditionnel en disant bah non
en fait nous on est des patrons on est
des dirigeants d'entreprises surtout on
est progressiste on travaille avec nos
salariés on partage la valeur on
considère que l'urgence écologique et
sociale doit être le faire de l'ordre du
développement de nos entreprises etc
donc on veut porter des politiques
publiques qui homogénis et qui font pas
exister une distorsion de concurrence
parce qu'en fait quand vous produisez
bien vous réminerez bien vos salariés
bah vous êtes en distorsion de
concurrence par rapport à celui ou celle
qui va produire le bout de la planète à
des coûts extrêmement réduits avec des
matières premières dégueulasses qui
coûtent pas cher qui a besoin de moins
d'énergie pour survivre parce qu'on
parlait d'énergie tout à l'heure il y a
un grossier sur l'industrie j'aimerais
en parler peut-être après mais
donc Robin des concurrence et ça c'est
pas normal c'est pas normal qui est
cette primovis d'une certaine manière
que ce soit plus facile pour eux de
vendre au vice c'est à dire que en plus
les repris ça à qui je l'ai repris ça
Gaël Giraud je crois je la ferai la
gueule Jérôme elle a pris ma vie
surtout on a le tournevis c'est ça
le mal se comporter c'est à dire c'est
un jargon qui n'est pas le mien
d'ailleurs mais
quand vous discutez avec route des yeux
président du Medef vous avez déjà
discuté en fait
quand vous lui avez mis un petit chassé
[Musique]
des fonds les autres patrons
alors en plus il est sympa
pour le coup il est sympa ça on va pas
dire qu'il est pas simple
moi je pense que lui donc déjà il porte
une organisation qui est plus puissante
que lui c'est à dire que il représentant
du medefroid je l'ai quand même puissant
il est puissant en tant mais jamais
accorder trop de puissance à un individu
il doit développer
450 watts au minimum
il connaît beaucoup de monde mais c'est
aussi par son gros low Medef que il a
cette place dans la société civile
essentiellement
ce qui veut faire lui c'est le moindre
relation en fait c'est vraiment pour moi
lui défend une économie dérégulier voilà
donc en fait à partir de ce moment là en
fait on s'entend pas parce que pour lui
nous on veut on veut réguler on veut
créer des objectifs des et pour lui le
marché existe et là en fait déjà on
n'est pas d'accord sur le postulat pour
nous marcher il n'existe pas il y a une
incitation à faire à faire les choses
mal et malheureusement moi je trouve
qu'il représente beaucoup trop
aujourd'hui
donc à faire développer son activité
économique dans des conditions de
destruction c'est à dire en extrayant ce
qui nous appartient pas en ne rémunéré
pas bien de salariés en partageant pas
bien la valeur
en réduisant les coûts un maximum donc
en ne payant pas finalement le coût
environnemental etc donc voilà produire
mal distribué mettre beaucoup de CO2
enfin bon si vous voulez tout ce qui
pourrait être vu comme mal fait dans
l'économie quoi en tout cas pas au
service des individus au service de la
planète
et après lui il a une vision qui partage
aussi pas mal j'ai vu plusieurs
grands dirigeants économiques qui est le
fait qu'en fait sans croissance il y a
pas des tasses où il y a pas d'état
Providence il y a pas de liberté et en
plus ça et le mythe de la liberté c'est
quand même c'est quand même un gros
problème moi je me sens pas libre dans
l'économie de marché aujourd'hui moi je
me sens obligé plutôt à
avoir des pratiques qui sont vertueuses
pour la société pour la planète donc je
me sens cadenassée dans une économie qui
en fait
valorise les produits peu chers
valorise les entreprises qui sont
capables de licencier du jour au
lendemain parce que ça améliore le PNL
le bilan
valorise l'hyper croissance et moi
l'hyper croissance je sais que dans le
milieu des start-up c'est ce qui pollue
l'hyper croissance c'est la Supra
croissance c'est-à-dire c'est même pas
la croissance on parle l'hyper
croissance et ça c'est très mauvais pour
la voiture de toutes les startups
d'ailleurs est souvent compliquée
complexifié par l'hypercroissance c'est
à dire que c'est compliqué de passer
d'une entreprise de enfin c'est des
humains qui développent des entreprises
c'est pas des robots c'est pas des
algorithmes donc développer une boîte en
passant de 30 à 500 salariés
bah oui c'est compliqué on fait des on
fait des mauvais choix on essaie
d'industrialiser le plus possible on
essaie d'avoir de moins de ressources
humaines possibles d'ailleurs c'est très
drôle on fait des burn out absolument
c'est limite la version
marxiste
plutôt sur la partie industrielle qui
est finalement pour trouver dans
certains modèles d'entreprise actuelle
c'est à dire on épuise une partie du
peuple on les essor on les et puis
ensuite on renouvelle etc
et en fait l'économie ne veut pas
fonctionner comme ça ça c'est le
débouché de la crise sociale c'est un
État providence qui a effectivement
besoin de beaucoup plus de ressources
parce que les gens sont en mauvaise
santé sont pas heureux c'est pas
vertueux ni pour l'État providence ni
pour l'économie ni pour les gens en
combien de temps vous évaluez ce
changement de paradigme entre votre
perception de ce qu'il faudrait faire et
la réalité des marchés la réalité de
l'économie et ensuite on abordera le
côté guerre économique et géopolitique
des marchés
l'arme du dollar comment ça se passe
l'arme du Yoann comment ça se passe je
serai pas la meilleure interlocutrice
sur ça mais on peut on peut
aborder cette question moi je travaille
dans l'économie réelle combien de temps
selon vous entre la réalité de ce que
nous annonce le gilet et le changement
de paradigme de l'économie mondiale
alors ceux qui nous ont les humains sont
imprévisibles sont imprévisibles
bien sûr aujourd'hui on voit pas de
tendance de transformation forte
il y a un sujet générationnel qui peut
être intéressant peut-être
peut-être que
inch'Allah le fait que
l'enjeu de survivre que l'inspirante
survie prenne le dessus des générations
nouvelles que l'envie de faire des
enfants puissent comment continuer à
rester quelque chose qui qui est
généralisé que l'envie de bien vivre que
les modèles en fait d'écologiques soient
hyper désirable parce que finalement bah
ça intéresse plus trop de personnes de
consommer des trucs dégueulasses qu'on
jette
congètes et en fait de
travail trop que en fait c'est
générations ok on a tout à gagner à
développer ce modèle là donc on va faire
une on va on va insuffler une tendance
de fond que il y ait des dirigeants et
des leaders économiques parce que moi je
suis assez Utopia sinon je serais pas ce
que je fais donc très honnêtement je
crois en l'humanité quand même voilà
donc je pense que il y a une révolution
qui est en train de se passer les
révolutions sont souvent assez lentes
malheureusement je sais pas si on verra
la transformation je sais pas si du coup
on va pas
vous dire pour moi aujourd'hui on est
plus proche du 3-4 milliards de
personnes qui vont être victimes des
conséquences climatiques que du fait
qu'on arrive à atteindre un scénario de
réchauffement à virgule 5 degrés on est
aujourd'hui on est plus proche de ça si
on regarde tendance développe l'économie
et en même temps je vois les crises
elles sont tellement rapprochées
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on pensait la
crise énergétique tout est imbriqué la
crise géopolitique imbriquée avec la
crise énergétique imbriquée avec des
cris social et crise financières donc
envie de rester dans un système qui
renouvelle les crises de manière
systémique les gens se soulèvent les et
c'est l'essentiel de la population qui
vit ses crises là les personnes qui
peuvent qui peuvent penser
potentiellement vivre
sur un pilotique quoi son faibles
ils ont pas envie d'accueillir des gens
comme ça de nouvelles aventures
c'est un exemple très intéressant de
pays dans lequel il y a eu des
politiques publiques de bien-être qui
ont qui ont vraiment émergé donc c'est
un des premiers États à voir mis en
place aux côtés du PIB un indicateur
bien-être sur lequel il basait
l'ensemble de leur politique publique
donc c'est à l'époque de Jasmina Harden
qui est maintenant qui était
démissionnaire pour des raisons tout à
fait saines il y a beaucoup de
dirigeants devraient
prendre cet exemple là dans le sens où
un moment quand on épuisé quand on sait
plus qu'on comprend plus le peuple
aussi par leur construction
par la détermination etc je peux vous
couper vous avez des enfants non
je sais pas peut-être deux oui j'ai
envie de d'avoir des enfants je crois je
me bats pour pour
aussi plus personnelle on peut se battre
pour la vie pas vouloir la créer
je trouve ça beau déjà envie de aussi
d'insuffler de transmettre en fait de
transmettre surtout et si on transmet
pas en fait ouais dans un arrêté tout de
suite quoi si je pense que la fin c'est
la fin de ma génération bon moi je suis
pas je pense pas ça donc
puis on a fait des enfants aussi à plein
de d'époque bon
[Musique]
donc pourquoi pourquoi vous m'avez
essentialisé là d'un coup je vous ai
parlé de femme on avait essentialisé en
disant ce que vous voulez des enfants ça
c'est quand même assez marrant mais bon
Nouvelle-Zélande donc effectivement
la construction sociale féminine qui est
quand même je sais pas si vous
connaissez ces enquêtes
une sociologue Suzanne je vous enverrai
le lien dans les commentaires
montre que effectivement c'est entre 4
et 7 ans qu'on apprend au petit garçon à
ne pas montrer leur vulnérabilité ni
leurs qualités d'empathie et à valoriser
le fait qu'il le montre le moins
possible et on apprend exactement la
même période aux petites filles
apprendre soin de
leur écosystème même quand elles sont
toutes petites elles doivent prendre
soin c'est quand même fou et surtout
à ne pas prendre trop de risques et à
développer une qualité d'écoute et à se
censurer
donc les deux aspects
ont peuvent créer des deux
socialisations en tout cas peuvent avoir
des impacts positifs et négatifs pour le
genre et pour la société sauf
qu'aujourd'hui la socialisation du soin
est une socialisation qui est une
évidence et une obligation pour la
société c'est pour moi la clé de réponse
en partie à la transformation de nos
sociétés la raison pour laquelle
l'hôpital public est si maltraité la
raison pour laquelle on traite aussi mal
les gens en première ligne la raison
pour laquelle
voilà le travail du soin et le soin
globalement que une société apporte et
pas évaluée d'un point de vue financier
c'est pour deux raisons la première
c'est parce qu'on juge que c'est quelque
chose de féminin et que ça n'appartient
pas au marché ça n'appartient pas à
l'économie
d'ailleurs on crée on crée un genre
féminin en fait de cette manière-là et
de deux aussi c'est parce qu'on
considère que c'est un productif je sais
pas si vous êtes au courant mais la
science économique libérale le père
fondateur Adam Smith a quand même créé
toute une pensée économique autour du
fait que le seul travail qui vaut
salaire et le travail dit productif la
production de bien donc tout ce qui
appartient à la sphère privée c'est la
sphère des sentiments moraux
faire un dîner c'est pas un sentimental
donc en gros il a créé toute cette
espèce d'économiques ou en fait ça
n'avait pas de valeur donc ça ça a eu
des impacts en cascade parce que si le
travail du soin n'a pas de valeur bah du
coup bien sûr tout ce qui s'affine ni au
travail du soin et où non rémunéré ou
sous rémunéré et c'est très drôle et il
y a un livre très intéressant non ce qui
est drôle c'est ce que je vais vous dire
maintenant ce qui est très drôle c'est
que Adam Smith lui-même il y a un livre
très drôle qui s'appelle pour le coup le
dîner d'Adam Smith qui montre que il se
base sur le dîner d'Adam Smith donc Adam
Smith quand il est rentré de ses études
ou de ton travail il rentrait chez lui
donc il avait accès enfin la raison pour
laquelle il mangeait un steak ou machin
c'était parce que du coup la personne
qui lui a vendu avait maximisé son
intérêt particulier lui vendre le steak
lui il avait besoin de le manger donc ça
avait été acheté etc etc en fait que le
dîner selon l'économie libérale et
finalement le seul truc qu'il avait pas
évalué c'est qui préparait son dîner et
dams et habitait chez sa maman en fait
Adam Smith était un vieux garçon
et c'est la personne qui lui faisait son
dîner c'était sa mère et ça c'est un
travail introductif qui n'a jamais
valorisé
c'est une anecdote mais qui dit beaucoup
en fait qui dit beaucoup qui dit
beaucoup et donc aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on a une société dans
laquelle on dévalorise on ne valorise
pas économiquement en tout cas toute la
sphère du soin donc la sphère
effectivement de la santé dans un sens
large donc l'écologie la nature la
préservation de l'environnement la
préservation de la maison le foyer
l'éducation l'éducation des enfants et
donc l'éducation au sens large
les vieux effectivement parce que c'est
absolument cette transmission qui n'est
pas valorisée et c'est toute la sphère
qu'on a besoin de développer aujourd'hui
c'est tout ce dont la société manque
aujourd'hui donc c'est un switch qu'il
faut qu'il faut vraiment un switch pas
parler c'est un
transformation un salto arrière qu'il
faut que l'économie opère est déjà elle
doit démarrer sur les fondamentaux qui
est que les modèles économiques ne
peuvent pas fonctionner si le valorise
pas le travail du soin et du coup si en
valorisant le travail du soin les
modèles économiques ne sont plus viables
parce qu'on est en payant le sens on se
rend compte que ça fonctionne plus c'est
que l'économie libéra le et néolibérale
en fait ne fonctionne pas c'est le Japon
un peu très peu on n'est pas d'acier
ouvert
il y a des EHPAD assez ouvert au Japon
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il faudra taxer les robots
selon vous est-ce que vous investissez
dans l'intelligence artificielle les
robots est-ce que votre fond il investit
là-dedans
je pense moi je vois de toute façon vous
voyez bien dans mon parcours c'est à
dire que je vois la technologie la
finance comme des outils
au développement d'une d'un progressisme
social écologique donc il y a la
robotique fait partie des outils qui
peut être utilisé à dessin positifs et
qui peuvent se servir strictement à rien
parce que je trouve intéressant ou être
limite néfaste quand on veut utiliser
une technologie nous ce qu'on se dit
souvent d'ailleurs même quand on
développe c'est est-ce qu'on peut faire
plus simplement déjà avant même de se
poser la question est-ce qu'elle existe
la techno parce que moi je suis dans ma
plateforme je pourrais vous mettre de la
blockchain des machins des dédain gris
mais il y en a pas parce que ça n'a
aucune utilité ça va juste effectivement
consommer plus pas chez moi en tout cas
moi un service de paiement classique me
permettrait bien de fonctionner j'ai pas
besoin de mettre de la blockchain
aujourd'hui parce qu'en plus c'est
beaucoup trop énergivore etc
mettre de la vidéo qui ressort de
partout ouais ce serait ce serait génial
parce que l'expérience serait mais non
j'en ai pas besoin pour que les gens
elle se fait à travers aujourd'hui des
serveurs qui sont hyper légers à travers
un service bancaire pour le coup qui est
mon copain chez nous en l'occurrence
les services bancaires ont aussi pas
être complètement les remplacés par la
techno ça a pas de sens ça peut
accélérer nous une petite technologie
pour accélérer en accessible les
investissements donc en tout cas quand
on a l'usage d'une tech déjà on se
demande est-ce qu'on peut faire
autrement est-ce que est-ce que vraiment
on a besoin et ensuite si on en a besoin
on réfléchit pour quels usage réellement
et le problème dans la technologie
globalement c'est la généralisation de
la technologie qui est disponible et
c'est comme la création monétaire vous
voyez à chaque fois enfin moi j'ai la
vie la même avis sur tout création
monétaire technologies ça a du sens
quand c'est ciblé à des à des fins de
prospérité d'une société
votre lecture de l'inflation c'est à
cause des banques centrales qu'on
vajecter à gogo pour sauver le système
de l'Ancien Monde c'est parce qu'il y a
une guerre c'est parce qu'il y a une
réflexion des ressources et pourquoi
t'y gorgée doit avoir la flèche
qui ne vit pas l'inflation le robinet
parisienne je vous en
prie mais alors l'inflation aujourd'hui
que nous on connaît elle est liée à
plusieurs phénomènes
la question énergétique est la question
principale très honnêtement on regarde
dans des industries très précises leur
facture énergétique nous accompagne une
très belle industrie de filiatures de
lynx qui s'appelle belle Corrèze
et qui aujourd'hui vu ça facture belle
correct filature de lin
basée en France
vous faites de l'évasion fiscale de
l'optimisation fiscale vous pouvez
continuer rien du tout
[Rires]
donc belle Corex eux ils développent la
filature l'un ils ont racheté des usines
qui avaient qui étaient victimes de la
délocalisation les 1 million 900 000
emplois selon la Cour des comptes là la
référence perdue depuis les années 80
sont essentiellement liés à des
localisation en grande majorité du
secteur textile donc le pari reprend les
usines recréer une filière de
filaturelin c'est une boîte qui
économiquement fonctionne super bien
mais voilà crise énergétique 700 000 à 3
millions la facture de gaz
en fait comment vous survivez à ça de
nouveau survivez pas donc qu'est-ce que
vous faites dans ces cas-là
vous vendez un absolument ce qu'on
demande concrètement à cette entreprise
de faire aujourd'hui donc nous on est en
train en train de faire du lobbying etc
pour sauver cette boîte parce que c'est
quoi c'est quoi 2 millions 3 en fait
pour pour sauver une boîte qui est le
fleuron de l'industrie textile française
la compagnie des amendes sur la
plateforme
donc qu'est-ce que vous faites quand
vous êtes face à ça pour vous pour
expliquer ce domaine d'inflation en fait
bah où vous avez la possibilité
d'augmenter vos prix parce que votre
boîte elle est résiliente au fait qui
est moins de gens qui vont consommer
parce que augmenter les prix c'est moins
de gens qui consomment c'est des risques
où vous avez pas la possibilité parce
que vous êtes déjà en tension économique
parce que vous êtes une PME et pas une
boîte qui a une capitalisation de malade
que vous avez vécu le covid que vous
avez voilà donc vous pouvez pas
augmenter vos prix sinon vous perdez vos
clients et ils vont aller acheter
ailleurs chinois galets
et là en fait vous allez en crise vous
êtes dans la session sauf que la plupart
en fait ils sont obligés de malgré tout
d'augmenter leurs prix et donc voilà
donc en fait l'inflation elle s'analyse
par filière elle peut s'analyser les
filières qui sont très énergies forts
comme l'industrie textile elle peut
s'analyser aussi dans la filière
alimentaire donc là pour le coup la
filière alimentaire à la commune forte
période d'inflation qui était liée
notamment à la question de du blé
d'accord du blé il y a eu voilà
énormément qui était lié à la guerre
aussi et aussi la question énergétique
parce que ça consomme de l'énergie de
produire aussi de l'alimentation donc ça
ça fait augmenter les prix si vous
voulez et en fait l'essentiel de
l'inflation d'ailleurs je pense que
votre communauté le sait et que vous le
savez mais c'est essentiellement sur les
biens de première nécessité donc c'est
essentiellement les les gens comme comme
vous aimez encore mais moi pour le coup
là j'arrive à impacter l'inflation parce
que j'ai la chance quand même de faire
passer une classe moyenne mais les
personnes qui sont en précarité
aujourd'hui bah en fait l'inflation
c'est alors tout leur budget et même ça
leur empêche de vivre dignement de
manger de se loger
et là il y a un problème et le problème
que ce soit pas porté politiquement il y
a un bouclier énergétique etc un
bouclier d'arriver mais en fait ça
impacte pas l'ensemble des biens de
première nécessité et c'est un vrai
problème aujourd'hui donc voilà
des supermarchés avec des choses pas
cher c'est Bruno qui est dit c'est Bruno
Le Maire qui l'a dit ses copains des
supermarchés
des paniers un peu avant préparer
d'accord donc en fait en gros les seules
personnes qui doivent changer leur
manière de faire c'est les personnes les
plus précaires donc parce que vous
inquiétez pas que les personnes
précaires je pense que vous vous
inquiétez pas mais elles connaissent
l'écologie c'est à dire que l'écologie
de la vie elle l'a vu au quotidien les
la seconde main pour pour habiller les
enfants le font déjà
d'être capable d'acheter plutôt des
quantités importantes et de les et de
les consommer sur le reste de la semaine
elles le font elle part pas beaucoup en
vacances bon elles ont des plupart des
découvertes où elle parle pas en
vacances du tout et quand elles le font
bah c'est sur souvent pas très éloigné
du domicile voilà il y a la question
plus la mobilité qui est un vrai sujet
pour les classes dont je vais pas parler
nécessairement voilà là
si vous voulez prendre le temps il y a
le temps c'est gentil mais en tout cas
moi le point que je voulais plutôt
amener ici c'était de dire que
si c'est gentil mais c'est la parole
vous savez aujourd'hui les temps les
temps font que c'est compliqué quand
même d'avoir des espaces comme ça donc
merci quand même pour cet espace donc
voilà voilà l'inflation pourquoi elle
est autant vécue et je crois que les
derniers chiffres mais ça évolue
vraiment tous les jours c'est plus de
plus de 15% sur les biens rien nécessité
aujourd'hui l'inflation donc et en
global on est autour de 6 ça va
communiquer avec
j'en suis sûr donc pour vous dire à quel
point voilà c'est vraiment
en moyenne si aujourd'hui en France
ça dépend on est bien ça dépend des
biens pour l'alimentation absolument
c'est ce que je vous dis sur les biens
de première nécessité donc pour moi
l'alimentation ça en fait partie sauf
que calcul l'inflation il se fait sur un
panel beaucoup plus large donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut toujours s'intéresser
comme ça oui c'est sûr parce qu'ils ont
pas de politique ciblée absolument c'est
comme les politiques d'investissement
post covid on s'intéresse pas à ce qui
est vraiment financé d'ailleurs pardon
je dis ça j'en vois un peu des billes
comme ça mais je trouve que c'est
important parce que ça permet de faire
le lien aussi avec ce que je disais tout
à l'heure sur la question du travail du
son et comment il est évalué pour lui
donner aussi une existence concrète et
donner une existence concrète à ce que
je dis sur les 100
des centaines
de milliards qui ont été investis dans
les plans de relance c'est que 7% qui a
été dédiée à des métiers féminins
donc la crise et les crises elles
appauvrissent principalement des femmes
et les personnes qui sont dans le
travail du son les personnes âgées
les femmes âgées encore pire les
personnes âgées ça dépend de la
sociologie
certaines rues certaines rues les
petites vieilles sont obligées de ce
cotiser pour faire venir leur camion de
fioul parce que la livraison minimum
c'est 500 litres et elles font comme
dans les pays du tiers-monde elle se
ravitaille au jerrican parce que elles
sont cotisées pour faire venir 500
litres
un exemple encore effectivement la
catastrophe par exemple typiquement sur
les feux de forex etc on l'a vu très
concrètement que l'essentiel des décès
c'était des femmes de plus de 60 ans
parce que elles sont du coup précarisées
énergétiquement elles sont précarisées
tout court elles sont isolées et elles
ont pas les moyens effectivement du coup
de pouvoir se déplacer rapidement
et elles sont moins en plus connectées
et moins prévenu et cette RC c'est très
sûr c'est très surprenant mais voilà
donc en gros voilà à peu près
l'économie finalement reflète
reflète ce désastre se désastres
sociétales
je sais pas aujourd'hui quoi
elle préfère donc les services
centralisés ou services décentralisés
point d'interrogation c'est une question
de Jérémy
elle
est plus en faveur d'une politique
nationale la dame pour notamment faire
ce que je vous ai dit ça va avoir des
politiques publiques qui sont ciblées
par exemple vers la transition
énergétique etc il faut de la
centralisation quand même c'est bien il
faut qu'un moment il y ait une politique
centrale d'ailleurs européenne
communautaire ou nationale qui disent la
création monétaire c'est vers la
transition écologique qui disent la
fiscalité elle fonctionne selon des
principes de pollueurs payeurs qui dit
voilà on a un plan de relance on veut
80% d'investissement dans la transition
il y a besoin d'un organe national fort
qui puisse effectivement de une réguler
comme on disait tout à l'heure mais en
plus diriger les politiques publiques et
administrer les politiques publiques
décider d'un budget bien-être pour
agréger l'économie globale etc
le bouton effectivement c'est un exemple
intéressant comme au bouton comme en
Nouvelle-Zélande comme en Finlande ou
c'était la ministre de l'économie qui
disait
où elle firstate donc l'état proverbe
désolé parce que je voulais vraiment la
citer donc l'étape Providence
l'État providence
doit être nourri par l'économie et pas
et pas l'inverse c'est à dire que c'est
pas l'état providence qui doit nourrir
l'économie c'est l'économie qui doit
nourrir l'État-providence qui t'a
proposé
donc en gros c'est
expérimenté pareil un budget bien-être
et ça fonctionne très bien en fait donc
pour tout ça pour avoir des politiques
publiques sortir du PIB la lecture
unique des politiques publiques pour
pouvoir avoir des politiques fortes dans
la transition pour pouvoir planifier
aussi moi je suis en faveur d'une
planification là la transition
écologique elle doit se faire rapidement
et pour ça c'est la nécessité de
planification donc pour ça vous répondez
la deuxième question que Jérémie
seront-elle compte qu'on a plus le temps
d'attendre l'échelle est tellement
courte on ne peut pas compter sur les
générations futures c'est à nous d'agir
maintenant sans attendre
sérieusement pas compte de l'urgence
point d'interrogation
c'est vrai que je me rends pas compte je
dédie ma vie à cette urgence vous
inquiétez pas je me rends compte de
l'urgence et je pense que les
générations quand je dis nouvelle
génération c'est les nations qui peuvent
agir dès maintenant et elles agissent
déjà dans les entreprises dans les dans
les groupes politiques etc et et moi je
travaille avec les anciennes générations
parce que justement et avec le milieu
bancaire etc parce que pour moi
déjà si on n'a pas d'argent mais fait ce
signe si on n'a pas d'argent on ne fait
rien donc la transition écologique se
fait avec du financement de la
transition écologique et pour se fout
travailler avec ceux effectivement qui
en ont sans concession donc moi c'est
des moments très garder ma radicalité
tout en étant dans le dialogue et
pouvant aussi travailler sur la question
de l'investissement
et je sais qu'on n'a pas le temps et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un enjeu de
planification et c'est important
mais par contre il y a une partie de
planification qui doit être
décentralisée prenons l'exemple
typiquement de la donc quand on parle
aussi beaucoup mais je pense à toujours
important de le rappeler la rénovation
énergétique pour le coup il y a un gros
problème sur la rénovation énergétique
par notamment le phénomène de
centralisation du financement de la
rénovation énergétique aujourd'hui la
rénovation énergétique le financeur
principal c'est la Caisse des Dépôts
sauf que le modèle de financement de la
rénovation énergétique est proposé c'est
un modèle avec de la dette qui a un taux
variable les collectivités elles perdent
leur subventions en ce moment elles ont
des modèles économiques qui sont qui
sont compliqués et donc elles ont peur
d'emprunter à ce variables avec
notamment ce qu'on ce qui se passe etc
absolument donc elles ont peur en fait
d'emprunter comme ça et c'est
compréhensible donc je pense qu'il y a
une vraie question de
de décentraliser les organes de
financement de la de la rénovation
énergétique il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
est mis sur la table par contre la
Caisse des Dépôts met de l'argent
combien d'argent aujourd'hui la caisse
des poètes utilise le fond d'épargne
pour pouvoir faire ses placements là
c'est à peu près 30%
des livrets à livrer développement
durable et solidaire
qui sont placés dans le logement sociaux
et à peu près 45 sur la transformation
énergétique donc on va dire on va dire
45% en moyenne ça mes sources elles sont
très très claires il y a un rapport
livré à ldds qu'on a publié sur notre
site rift on vous montre du coup
effectivement dans livret A livré
développement durable et solidaire
qu'est-ce qui est vraiment financé dans
la qu'est-ce qui financerait réellement
pardon de la transition énergétique et
le logement social donc c'est à peu près
il y a un montant énorme c'est à peu si
vous compilez livrer à et ldds c'est à
peu près 500 milliards donc si vous
prenez à peu près 45% de ça s'il y a des
mailles financières très importantes
pour la rénovation énergétique sauf que
le modèle économique qui est proposé aux
collectivités aujourd'hui visiblement
pour elle c'est pas un modèle économique
à adapté il faut davantage effectivement
développer les subventions à la
transition ou des fonds ultra court
terme parce que ce à quoi s’appelle en
ce moment la Caisse des dépôts à
travailler sur cette vision très long
terme c'est encore le c'est encore le
même sujet il faut une vision ultra long
terme pour financer la rénovation
énergétique mais pour ça je pense qu'il
faut décentraliser effectivement une
partie du financement de cette
rénovation énergétique je voudrais
remercier le ns de vous avoir mis une
veste
moi aussi sinon j'aurais pas entrepris
je pense si le LS
moutons
je vais poser une question ça va nous
lancer sur un autre côté donc atterrir
un avis sur Aladin Blackrock qui gère
18000 milliards d'actifs
son intelligence artificielle
18 milliards d'actifs
on a un bon système en France et en fait
non ils ont rien trouvé quoi ils vous
attaquent ils vont faire un peu peur
quoi
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire une
procédure bailloné
mais c'est un géant qui est encore plus
peur qu'un financier et c'est un peu
c'est un peu stressant quoi mais en fait
quand vous savez que vous battez pour
les bonnes raisons et en fait voilà pour
le coup les régulateurs font leur boulot
quoi moi je me suis dit plutôt soutenu
que que à ce moment-là
donc Blackrock premier l'équivalent de
la croque en France en Europe on dit
donc des tailles pas exactement
similaires ne pas pas non plus très loin
mais surtout des participations dans les
entreprises à peu près similaires
qui gère tout ça c'est ça peut être
dangereux c'est quoi le problème en fait
de l'intelligence artificielle et de la
gestion d'actifs passive en fait de
BlackRock c'est qu'en fait ils mettent
partout
en fonction de ce qui se passe sur les
marchés
donc ils sont passifs c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont une gestion passive ils ont à
peu près que moi entre 4 et pour cent et
3% à peu près toutes les entreprises du
CAC 40 notamment en France et puis à
l'international ils ont l'équivalent
surtout les index ils ont une gestion
passive et du coup bah tant que le cours
de l'action il monte
il continue de gare de gérer quand il
baisse ils enlèvent et en fait ils
peuvent utiliser des fonds activistes
mais c'est pas les leurs c'est plutôt
d'autres des petits fonds pour faire le
taf d'un gérant en conseil
d'administration assemblée générale mais
eux ils bougent pas et ça
l'investissement passif ça a une vraie
difficulté parce que nous on veut
recréer cette transformation du secteur
financier par l'épargne globale par
l'épargne des plans d'épargne retraite
dès l'assurance vie en fait quand les
gestionnaires les premiers gestionnaires
c'est des investisseurs passifs donc des
gens qui en fait globalement ne
regardent que le cours de l'action et
pas vraiment ce qui est investi dans
l'entreprise c'est un problème parce que
si vous êtes en recherche d'augmentation
du cours vous laissez la possibilité à
des entreprises de faire des du rachat
d'action donc plutôt à faire
des opérations sur les marchés donc le
rachat d'action je sais pas si c'est
enfin je pense que tout le monde sait un
peu ce que c'est mais on rachète les
entreprises rachètent leur propre action
pour faire augmenter le cours de
l'action donc c'est à dire le cours de
l'action et la variation n'est pas liée
pardon juste à la stabilité économique
de l'entreprise
Macron a dit que il allait regarder de
plus près les rachats d'actions des
entreprises et les super profits
on travaille un peu avec le gouvernement
nécessairement parce qu'on fait du
lobbying
alors avant on était complètement
pas considéré aujourd'hui on est
consulté
de la culture on va leur convention on
rencontre les ministres on propose des
amendements et en fait nous on essaie de
montrer un truc que les entreprises
veulent aussi se transférer ce
changement parce que c'était soi-disant
à la base le parti des entreprises de
l'économie
nous on sent pas nécessairement aider
aujourd'hui et on essaie de défendre nos
industries quoi parce qu'en fait c'est
bien des réindustrialisation verte mais
quand on n'est pas capable de soutenir
du coup l'industrie textile en France
verte c'est quoi un plan d'industrie
industrialisation verte et nous on
essaye de faire ce travail pour leur
montrer bah non l'avenir de l'industrie
il est pas comme l'industrie d'hier ça
sert à rien de vouloir relancer les
entreprises qui en fait dans un monde
1,5 degrés n'ont pas lieu d'exister ce
qui est intéressant c'est de relancer le
tissu industriel sur lequel on avait
plus fortes émissions et oui c'est
compliqué de produire en France en fait
parce qu'on paye on paye le prix
d'énergie en France on voit le coût d'un
ouvrier et du coup cette primovis en
fait elle peut pas exister parce que
encore une fois vous avez le visage vous
voyez devant vous
avec les États-Unis
avec les États-Unis alors eux d'ailleurs
ils sont en train de se doter d'un plan
de réindustrialisation verte de tout
furieux à coups de milliard en fait ils
ont effectivement c'est une dimension
beaucoup plus importante nous on n'a pas
marché unifiant en Europe c'est ce qui
est en compliqué aussi le fait d'avoir
ce modèle en fait le modèle américain il
est pas vraiment en France ce qui est en
Europe pardon ce qui est ce qu'on
pourrait s'inspirer c'est d'avoir des
politiques en tout cas protectionniste
sur certaines filières plus fortes pour
pouvoir faire
pour développer certaines filières ça
veut dire une filière agricole une
filière qui est menacée par une forme de
concurrence une filière textile etc
l'idée pas du tout de se couper des des
interconnexions avec d'autres pays mais
d'avoir une coopération saine déjà avec
les forces économiques en place
puissante etc coopération saine d'éviter
d'être levacel ou l'esclave c'est
exactement cette espèce de
de lignes de fil entre je suis ton
esclave et je te domine et aujourd'hui
en fait on est l'esclave en 2000 moi
c'est comme ça que je vois la
géopolistique économique c'est que d'un
côté on extrait le moindre minerai en
déforestant trois quarts du continent
africain dont d'ailleurs dans certains
États qui sont aujourd'hui dont on rase
la biodiversité dont leur économie est
basée sur l'agriculture et le tourisme
donc on détruit des économies en vérité
si j'en conscience quand consomme du
pétrole pas maintenant mais quand on
développe de nouveaux projets pétroliers
maintenant aussi ça il y a eu des
mosquées bon maintenant c'est fait là on
développe il y a encore des nouveaux
projets pétroliers qui sont en train de
développer qui détruisent des économies
donc on va extraire comme si on pouvait
extraire à foison
beaucoup de beaucoup de pays
on se repose sur de la main d'oeuvre pas
cher mais derrière on est profondément
dominé nous-mêmes parce qu'on a
incapable de produire parce que
et l'idée est pas de produire tout tout
seul mais en fait de créer une
coopération saine avec un pays c'est sûr
que quand en fait on repose sur la main
d'oeuvre peu cher la production de nos
masques ou je ne sais n'importe quel
filière textile et qu'ensuite ben en
fait la personne la personne donc le
pays la Chine ou les États-Unis mais en
l'occurrence là je parlais plus de
l'Asie ils sont capables de vous menacer
en fait parce que en fait demain vos
prix vont concernement augmenter si vous
mettez en place une coopération saine
avec des états c'est-à-dire de bien
rémunérer les gens que vous faites
travailler là-bas par exemple en fait
tout le monde est content de coopérer
avec vous donc ils ont moins de la
capacité d'entrer dans une relation
domination si on fait ça
si on copère mieux si on rémunère tout
tout le monde sur terre correctement ça
va pas créer plus de demandes plus de
pression sur le biotope pas du tout par
exemple le rapport du gel vous montre
que la pire la pire chose pour une
société qui veut se transformer c'est
d'avoir une précarité sa société trop
élevée parce que quelqu'un qui est dans
une situation de précarité ne peut pas
s'adapter à la transition écologique et
ça nécessite des moyens s'adapter et
pour ça il faut justement que justice
sociale fort dans le monde et que les
gens aient des moyens si on veut qu'ils
puissent adapter aussi à la question
de la guerre économique
si on veut pas que s'adaptent et qu'on
garde tout pour nous mais en fait le
problème c'est que s'il y a bien un
sujet sur la question climatique c'est
que ça a touché tout le monde
c'est que même les leaders
se rapprochent
en fait dans notre cher c'est le gros
problème de l'empathie alors que les
questions des sécheresses des risques
physiques et climatiques sont vécus par
énormément d’états depuis non non mais
vous avez raison de caricature parce que
parfois on peut penser ça d'une certaine
manière aussi quand on voit là peut-être
que ça bouge pas
ces gens-là vivent déjà depuis très
longtemps enfin les questions
d'innovation 70% des vagues migratoires
elles sont liées à des questions
climatiques donc voilà donc déjà
respecter les personnes pour avec
lesquelles on travaille avec lesquels on
collabore d'un point de vue économique
c'est leur donner la capacité de
s'adapter c'est effectivement leur
permettre effectivement d'investir dans
la gros foresterie dans dans des vrais
industries c'est leur donner la capacité
aussi d'être moins précaire
énergétiquement donc d'être avoir un peu
pouvoir un peu plus voir un peu plus sur
le long terme etc donc c'est ça en fait
c'est ça pour tout le monde et et moi
j'ose espérer que la question de la
crise climatique
accompagnée d'une crise de la
biodiversité sans laquelle on va essayer
de chercher trop en fait si on regarde
que la crise climatique on va chercher
on va chercher des solutions très
spécifiques et on va se dire ok du coup
le sujet c'est que le climat donc on va
faire de l'énergie nucléaire à fond et
que ça et on s'en fout de comment on
extrait les minerait machin si on parle
aussi de condition de la biodiversité on
se rend compte que la préservation de la
biodiversité et la régénération de la
biodiversité de une c'est bon pour
climat c'est bon pour l'économie c'est
bon pour tout le monde là on peut
essayer de construire une économie saine
et j'ose espérer que que l'ensemble des
leaders voudront ça après l'air d'être
trop le chemin là
les leaders sont délitsés quoi perdre
leur leadership c'est quoi la dette
climatique la dette climatique c'est ce
que je vous expliquais tout à l'heure
c'est le fait que aujourd'hui
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique sont vécues en grande
majorité par les pays dites du Sud dit
en développement
[Musique]
il faut les sauver beaucoup moins d'été
occidentaux
et ils ont des ressources mais qui dont
ils ne peuvent pas jouir malheureusement
cause des marchés il y a une population
qui effectivement très jeune
mais malheureusement ces pays sont en
train de vivre des risques climatiques
développer et créé par l'industrie et
par les pays
occidentaux moi je dis pas nous parce
que je suis la première génération
immigrés d'Afrique du Nord donc j'ai du
mal avec le nous je me sens pas
je me sens redevable parce que je
privilégié mais pas parce que
aujourd'hui mais pas pas à cause de mes
ancêtres en tout cas
puis des générations
donc les pays occidentaux qui ont
consommé comme produit etc sont
responsables à la question de
réchauffement climatique le
réchauffement climatique et
essentiellement aujourd'hui vécu dans
ces risques physiques donc sécheresse
inondations etc par les pays qui sont
les moins consommateurs de ressources
énergétiques et qui aujourd'hui ont
effectivement sont aussi assis sur sur
leur propre source donc déjà ils peuvent
décider eux-mêmes s'ils peuvent
exploiter leurs propres ressources et
aujourd'hui c'est pas ce qui se passe
donc il y a une dette et la question de
la dette climatique elle pose la
question de à combien elle est cette
dette en fait combien on doit en fait
finalement combien les États qui ont
consommé doivent au pays qui vivent les
conséquences climatiques aujourd'hui ce
qui est évalué par un peu un organe
politique des pays du Sud qui se réunit
à la Coop c'est que les besoins sont
autour de 1000 milliards par an
et aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 100
milliards par an qui est réellement
qui est réellement placé à quoi ça sert
en fait la déclimatique à s'adapter
avoir des politiques d'agroécologie de
reforestation etc à pouvoir gérer aussi
les déplacements enfin voilà donc ça a
beaucoup beaucoup de défaits donc il y a
des par exemple il y a des fonds des
fois importants qui sont créés pour
pouvoir venir en soutien de l'activité
écologique à la transformation
écologique
et en fait le problème c'est que c'est
mille milliards la
conclusion de votre corps
la conséquence de la Coop de il y a
tout ça ici
c'est bon
désolé merci bien
il y a pas de difficulté
ah pardon et là c'est bon
et là c'est bon ok désolé
donc la COP donc ça fait déjà plusieurs
coques qui le disent ouais
la COP
c'est un peu enfin c'est toujours un peu
triste parce que ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'effectivement il y a donc il y a des
ressources dans les États qui doivent
être donc les États doivent payer la
dette climatique
mais il y a 50% des ressources qui
doivent être trouvées dans le milieu
privé dans la salle privée pour deux
raisons pour des raisons juste de qui a
l'argent
et pour des raisons de
qui doit payer en fait finalement qui
est responsable parce que c'est ça la
question en fait c'est ça la question
qui qui pose problème dans la société
qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à engager
une transformation profonde c'est qu'en
fait il y a une bataille culturelle
autour de qui est responsable les gens
se
pointent je dois
la catastrophique aujourd'hui les pays
africains on leur dit n'utilisez pas vos
ressources
oui il y a en plus ce gros problème
effectivement qu'on extrait les
ressources qu'on leur dit ne les
utilisaient pas voilà le rapport du GECK
pour votre propre consommation
après tout la question de de la
consommation des ressources fossiles
c'est la question de la consommation
c'est facile donc
si les pays africains extraient une
petite partie de leurs ressources pour
quand même pouvoir faire leur transition
et que les pays occidentaux type d'idées
drastiquement leur consommation qu'on
arrive à deux tonnes de CO2 en moyenne
ça irait mais sauf que ce sera pas le
cas donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui le
giaggy faut plus extraire les fossiles
du sol parce qu'avec les faux cils qui
sont déjà consommés
qui sont déjà extraits du sol et qu'on
va consommer on est déjà on atteint un
réchauffement à virgule 5 degrés sous
lequel on arrive encore à maîtriser les
conséquences climatiques au dessus d'un
virgule 5 degrés on ne maîtrise plus les
conséquences climatiques on a on ne peut
pas adapter les entreprises on ne peut
pas adapter notre système etc
à mon avis
avec plaisir
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que féminisme
c'est un mouvement d'ailleurs qui a pas
encore suffisamment percé en France
alors qui dans plein de pays est
considéré comme une vraie alternative
l'Echo féminisme c'est analyser le la
similarité c'est plusieurs choses mais
c'est déjà analyser la similarité entre
la violence que les hommes ont exercé
sur les femmes et la violence qu'ils ont
exercé sur la nature donc c'est
effectuer déjà ce parallèle
parce que finalement ce dont on ce dont
on meurt aujourd'hui
c'est finalement de la violence et de la
résonance du vivant de le fait que
l'humain a considéré le vivant là
extrait là être considéré comme son
objet et lui-même on est devenu objet de
son propre système etc donc les femmes
en gros socialisés comme femme
sont capables dans la théorie qu'au
féministe de comprendre déjà cette
violence parce qu'elles l'ont vécu
les femmes aussi parce qu'elles ont été
effectivement dominées et réduite mais
je dirais du 8 mais en fait je considère
que ce travail est positif au travail du
soin elles ont aussi une proximité très
forte avec la nature
cette proximité l'a fait qu'elles ont
développé des savoirs uniques en termes
de soins d'organisation de la famille en
termes de préservation du vivant mais
dans aussi dans son côté naturel
biodiversité etc
les femmes les femmes
[Musique]
l'essentiel des femmes c'est pas
nécessairement des femmes dans les pays
continentaux donc c'est dans aussi
beaucoup de pays après attention dans
les pays occidentaux c'est pareil il y a
pas que du urbain donc beaucoup dans
dans les zones rurales etc les femmes
des mini urbains c'est un autre sujet on
pourra en parler parce que c'est là
qu'on voit aussi le problème fort dans
le fait qu'aujourd'hui la seule voie
d'émancipation des femmes aujourd'hui
c'est la voix capitaine c'est-à-dire
qu'on vous dit si vous voulez vous
émanciper vous rentrez dans le système
traditionnel capitaliste vous bossez
comme des hommes vous faites tout pareil
pour 30% moins bien sûr faut pas abuser
non plus et d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
faire ce travail là vous allez en plus
utiliser une main d'oeuvre pour
s'occuper de votre famille qui que vous
allez encore plus vous dominer donc
voilà ma meuf peu cher etc pour garder
vos enfants etc
donc ça c'est des gros problèmes du
féminisme libéral pour moi d'une
certaine manière c'est que d'un côté moi
j'en suis aussi tributaire c'est à dire
que je travaille mais en essayant de
changer les choses et du coup les
co-féministes moi je trouve que la
personne qui représente le mieux les
qu'au féministes
féministe qui s'appelle van Dana Shiva
qui en fait dans son travail c'est un
peu un modèle je vous avoue aussi donc
vous avez beaucoup de similarités avec
des choses que j'ai pu vous dire dans
son travail elle fait un travail
militant un travail entrepreneurial un
travail de lobbying un travail spirituel
et culturel fort c'est elle mêle tout ça
un travail militant elle vis-à-vis de
l'industrie agroalimentaire et de
l'expansion des pesticides qui
détruisent la nature etc elle pour le
coup d'ailleurs on reparle du nazisme
mais
elle montre que les industries qui ont
développé les pesticides soit les
industries aussi qui ont développé
les gaz très longtemps en tout cas
dans milieu communauté on s'en souvient
encore quoi
qui ont utilisé les gaz pour exterminer
les Juifs
et du coup
pour elle on extermine la nature d'une
certaine manière avec ça aujourd'hui et
du coup elle mène un combat militant
fort contre cette industrie donc
vis-à-vis de ceux qui financent à
l'industrie vis-à-vis des gros groups
internationaux qui financent cette
industrie donc c'est changer quand même
depuis non pas
du tout pas du tout pour le coup dans ce
secteur là il y a pas eu de
transformation proprement parler
il s'agirait plutôt que les États
neutrisent pas sur leur propre sol
l'utilisation de ces choses-là ou
considère que des produits qui
détruisent concrètement on a besoin pour
vivre c'est un crime quoi mais bon ça
c'est encore plus topique
et c'est vendu et c'est vendu et c'est
réglementé
et ces réglementé dans certains pays
mieux que d'autres donc dans certains
pays on peut moins faire de choses vous
comprenez pourquoi je mets toutes ces
précautions parce que c'est aussi y
participe aussi éviter que les cultures
se fassent ravager par des saloperies
ils participent aussi à améliorer les
rendements ils participent aussi à
nourrir les gens
quand on fait bouffer des trucs qui
provoquent des problèmes de santé énorme
qui détruisent les sols
[Rires]
l'agro foresterie
enfin il y a beaucoup pour regarder le
travail qui est fait par pour une
agriculture du vivant par exemple etc
qui montre que aujourd'hui si on veut
avoir un autre salut alimentaire ça
passe par la régénération des sols et
pas par la destruction des sols avec
l'usage de certains pesticides
effectivement il y avait de toute façon
c'est globalement la question du rêve
libéral dont on revient c'est que toute
cette industrie alimentaire même de la
production de de toute la production le
fait de rendre accessible à consommation
de tout en grande quantité pas cher
c'était le rêve d'une époque c'était les
Trente Glorieuses mais maintenant on en
est on en est plus là quoi aujourd'hui
quand la croissance augmente le niveau
de pauvreté augmente enfin aujourd'hui
cette économie là ne génère plus de
salut et en plus elle ne protège pas les
idées travailleurs enfin voilà dans le
milieu agricole des personnes qui ont eu
des maladies extrêmement sérieuses qu'il
y a l'usage de ces pesticides
qui a réussi qui a réussi à faire valoir
son
mais il faudrait que ce soit un 4G est
prudence quoi
donc les copains donc bandana Shiva donc
c'est milité déjà contre les désastres
d'une industrie trop lourde etc oui
c'est un peu ce que j'essaie de faire
avec la finance et elle le fait avec la
question d'agroalimentaire que je
m'avais pas du tout à son niveau et
d'ailleurs c'est monté des alternatives
entrepreneuriales basées sur des savoirs
uniques et des savoirs simples donc si
vous voulez de la même manière que moi
j'ai réinventé la tontine quoi ça veut
dire on prend de l'argent des citoyens
va financer l'économie réelle et bah
elle elle travaille sur effectivement
l'agroécologie donc comment les
personnes déjà sont souverains sur leur
propre sol parce qu'il y a aussi ça
parce que derrière quand c'est des
industries effectivement très grosses du
coup les personnes travaillent sur leur
propre sol ne sont pas souverains à leur
propre sol ça ne leur appartient pas et
comment ils peuvent regénérer les sols
etc donc c'est monter des alternatives
entrepreneuriales basées sur des savoirs
uniques etc et c'est aussi une bataille
culturelle contre la culture de la
domination globalement et la défense
d'une culture de la coopération qui est
le salut clairement de l'humanité ça
peut nourrir une population
il y a rien qui montre que non il y a
rien qui montre que non absolument il y
a beaucoup d'études pour le coup là je
pense que vous avez peut-être aussi des
agronomes et ce sera peut-être plus
pertinent que moi mais en tout cas moi
avec conclusion que j'ai vu de des
différents plaidoyer qui sont menés par
ceux qui travaillent dans l'agriculture
et génératrice c'est que il y a une idée
reçue qui est effectivement la culture
industrielle produit beaucoup et que la
culture en agroforesterie etc produit
moins c'est faux ben c'est ce qui montre
en tout cas c'est stable
l'agroforesterie est-ce que est-ce que
aussi l'industrie chimique a apporté
aussi des bonnes choses comme la
stabilité la stabilité des rendements le
fait de moins être exposé aux
champignons où est exposé au ravageurs
est-ce que ça a permis d'apporter plus
de stabilité qu'avant
en fait le rêve c'était aussi surtout
effectivement de vendre massivement
aussi de rendre accessible les produits
moi je pense que c'est plus de
développer un maximum de profits pour
les industries mais parce qu'on sait que
le gaspillage alimentaire est très
important aussi donc finalement est-ce
qu'on a pas trop produit pour rien aussi
donc très honnêtement je n'en pour moi
je vois bien effectivement ce que la
période étranglorieuse de la
massification d'industrialisation de
les biens de consommation pour toutes et
tous etc a permis je me rends bien
compte c'est effectivement que tout le
monde est un emploi que tout le monde
puisse manger à sa fin machin etc quand
la croissance économique encore une fois
était liée
encore à cette époque là à la croissance
de l'espérance de vie depuis les chocs
pétroliers c'est fini tôt c'est fini tôt
et là on est en train encore de vivre
des crises nautiques alors qu'on avait
déjà un petit peu j'aime pas dire les
choses comme ça parce que c'est comme si
en fait nous on avait tout vu et moments
progressistes
surtout qu'en plus clairement je l'ai
pas vu je suis né pendant la période de
la financarisation je suis né dans les
années 90 j'ai 32 ans 33 cette année
donc moi j'ai rien vu ce qui me permet
aussi de pas regretter quoi que ce soit
c'est peut-être ça aussi moi j'ai plus
vu les désastres de cette économie là la
précarisation des emplois
le fait que c'était pas vraiment
désirable en fait de consommer des
choses qu'on jette en deux secondes
enfin plus on passe à la machine enfin
ça a aucun sens en fait ça n'a aucun
sens que le culte aussi productiviste
nuit aux êtres humains
qu'en fait on considère les hommes comme
les hommes les hommes et les femmes
comme des comme des machines que que le
fait de pas considérer le travail du
soin ça faisait que bah on se retrouvait
à travailler dix fois plus pour 10 fois
moins qu'on est une femme donc très
honnêtement je vois pas trop les
bénéfices moi de ce monde-là je vois
plus les bénéfices de l'économie
alternative et du monde alternatif qu'on
peut créer et c'est ça qu'en fait je
trouve dommageable c'est pas utopique en
fait de dire ça c'est que c'est
dommageable dans la mesure où ça va
aider la majorité de la population ce
monde-là auquel on aspire qui a intérêt
à ce que les personnes les plus aisées
les gros industries etc puissent
bénéficier l'ensemble de la source
financière qui a intérêt à ça qui a
intérêt à consommer des trucs qu'on
jette tout le temps qui a intérêt à
travailler 72 heures bon moi je
travaille plus que 112 heures mais mon
choix au moins pas de
mais ils sont pas ils sont gentils
voilà donc
très honnêtement je pense que ce monde
est désirable
et que
mais qu'il a besoin qu'il a besoin de
soutien que par contre il a besoin de
justice parce qu'on peut pas faire des
politiques écologiques décroissantes
sans considérer que il faut d'abord
aider les personnes qui sont le plus
exposées ça c'est le gros problème des
de
ça c'est le gros problème des politiques
de transition écologique façon
aujourd'hui c'est les formes de ben en
fait ça va être les mêmes pour tout le
monde ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas de
sens
et c'est le je pense que c'est les
problèmes aussi de certains décroissants
c'est que en fait la décroissance oui
mais en fait si elle est pas planifiée
c'est que de la pauvreté quoi et c'est
tout à fait ça
la récession et de la pauvreté mais en
tout cas d'un point de vue individuel de
croissance pas planifier enfin c'est
juste une précarisation donc par contre
une décroissance planifiée de
revalorisation des métiers de la
première ligne de meilleur partage des
richesses dans une société dans une
entreprise de créer des métiers vers
dans l'agriculture dans la rénovation
bah ça c'est une économie qui va
apporter de la c'est une décroissance
qui va apporter de la prospérité c'est
même plus une décroissance en fait moi
d'ailleurs ça m'intéresse même pas la
décroissance c'est une économie non
extractiviste qui protège qui revalorise
le travail du soin voilà c'est ça
je vais donner un peu de ma personne
chose que je me refuse à chaque fois de
faire
les gens comme vous j'en ai j'en ai
croisé et
leur motivation en fait c'est qu'ils ont
extrapolé les risques et ils sont mis à
voir les risques réels
auquel le nom changement allait nous
exposer
vous avez fait des cauchemars de la non
transition est-ce que ça vous a hanté
est-ce que vous avez vu les
répercussions
moi j'ai plus fait des cauchemars
de
la dictature
je pense que donc là c'est pas ma
société de femmes c'est ma socialisation
de femmes juives en France on a quand
même un peu peur que
même si on sent pas toujours aussi enfin
on se sensibilait on sent d'autres
populations et d'autres minorités
ciblées et on voit à quel point en fait
la une crise économique une crise
financière ça peut détruire le lien
social et ça peut nous mener à des
choses que l'humain
n'est pas censé ce que l'humain n'est
pas censé être exposé quoi
et donc moi c'est plus ça qui me fait
peur pour être tout à fait honnête
parce que de toute façon même le rapport
déjà que montre la planète se régénère
c'est l'humanité qui va se détruire et
elle commence comment on se détruisant
en se tuant exterminant
elle commence avec des politiques
dictatoriales voilà et donc c'est plus
ça moi qui m'est prêt hein
absolument ouais c'est ça qui me fait
peur nous on a toujours
considéré qu'on était capable de
déracine et très rapidement et moi ouais
j'ai grandi en France et je tiens en
fait à stabilité parce que
dans le sens comment on vit les choses
dans notre temps parce qu'en fait si on
vit pas ce que vous dites si on vit pas
les choses peut-être parce que vous
dites exactement parce que tu dis mais
c'est un peu ça c'est à dire si on dit
pas le truc dans sa chair c'est
compliqué d'être dans ce niveau
d'engagement moi je vis dans ma chair
cette peur d'être déracinée au seiniser
mis sur le pilori de nouveau et surtout
de voir les autres parce que je suis un
caractère extrêmement empathique c'est à
dire je pleure quand je jouais avec
quelqu'un et du coup j'ai peur de ça
j'ai peur de voir ça de la société et en
fait j'essaie de reprendre espoir dans
la société en le dialogue et pour ça ça
nécessite des politiques de stabilité
écologique et sociale et c'est pour ça
que moi personnellement je m'engage
voilà est-ce que vous avez est-ce que tu
as un sujet que tu voudrais aborder
on a parlé tellement de choses
alors
en plus donc ça me permettra de parler
de lui Achille même B qui a un
philosophe
qui a fait qui a capacité
du beaucoup de temps à Johannesburg
dans un livre que je vous conseille qui
s'appelle brutalisme c'est une vraie
critique du néolibéralisme assez
intéressantes assez poussée et ce qui
est participé particulièrement
intéressant c'est ce qui est ce que lui
il appelle le devenir maigre de la
société
occidentale donc c'est l'idée que
avec la crise climatique des pays
occidentaux sont en train d'expérimenter
l'esclavagisation qu'ils ont fait vivre
et sont esclavagés
en fait et je trouve que c'est une
perspective intéressante et il appelle
aussi justement à regarder des modèles
aussi de développement d'agroécologie
etc qui
parce qu'une certaine manière
quand on a été c'est la même chose
qu'avec la question du féminisme quand
on a été oppressé victime on a développé
des savoirs uniques en préservation des
instinctes survie et du coup on a
beaucoup à apprendre donc d'où l'intérêt
encore de la coopération mais en tout
cas c'est un bouquin philosophique qui
résume très bien les choses
ensuite j'invite à lire le travail de
vente d'anach Shiva mais ça ça va sans
dire qu'il y a du coup qui vous donnera
toutes les statistiques que vous voulez
pour comprendre effectivement les gros
problèmes de l'industrie
agroalimentaire
et qui permettra de comprendre tout son
travail aussi les cibles le travail de
militantisme de spiritualité aussi qu'il
faut faire pour passer une nouvelle
société
il y a le bouquin un office d'Eichmann
que je vous ai conseillé aussi goutter
rendors qui est violent quoi franchement
quand je l'ai étudié en philo justement
après avoir étudié avec des guerres et
un arène c'est tout donc c'était
d'ailleurs le compagnon d'anarenne
pendant une période lui il est sans
commune mesure encore plus violent et
les lectures encore plus violente de la
société que Anna à Rennes sur la
question du totalitarisme lui il a une
lecture voilà vraiment vous avez vu
quand même très très dur mais ça fait un
choc fort même si c'est toujours pas que
ce soit effectivement
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
vivre ce qui est certain c'est que en
tout cas ça fait un choc et ça fait
réaliser que on n'est pas juste des
atomes quoi que on aimerait
responsabilité
le travail de vinasse ça sert à rien de
le lire sans incompréhensible moi je ne
peux étudier les vitesses quand on me
parlant de l'épine c'est d'écouter en
les mineurs très dures de de lire et
voilà je vous ai déjà donné déjà trois
références que je trouve assez
assez englobante de de ce dont on a pu
parler aujourd'hui et assez différente
de ce que vous avez l'habitude de voir
ici
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable
c'est horrible
américain
déclaration c'est ça déclaration state
un peu facile quoi mais
je trouve que cette question de
l'innocence qui permet vraiment les
systèmes ne vous faites pas influencer
par le fait qu'on vous fasse croire que
c'est trop compliqué à comprendre que
enfin très honnêtement moi j'avais un
bagage culturel mais très très léger
une culture économique inexistante une
culture financière inexistante à
l'origine un réseau inexistant enfin
vraiment quoi il y a pas il y a rien qui
prédéterminaient à part
une culture entrepreneuriale un peu un
peu importante dans le sens
pas être capable cette école là pour
information j'ai eu même au Baco
rattrapage donc c'était la cata à la
base donc voilà donc clairement déjà ces
médias sont accessibles mais ils sont
pas que désirables réinventer vos
propres métiers réinventer le monde
en apprenant de ces milieux là en
dialoguant travaillant avec mais en
essayant d'apporter des nouvelles
lunettes on a considérablement besoin
d'innovation elle se trouve pas que dans
la high tech clairement pas elle peut se
trouver dans des choses simples donc
essayons de réinventer avec notre
effectivement notre société et surtout
de ne pas juger les uns les autres de
pas se seraiser les sons ça les sont ça
j'ai vu on sait ce soir où il y a une
fille qui parlait d'un génération en
moins voilà laissons ça à la génération
au moins
très honnêtement non on est capable de
dialoguer voilà c'est le salut de la
société qui passera par ça
merci à vous pour l'invitation
[Rires]
[Musique]